les retransmises en direct sur Public
Sénat et sur notre site internet au nom
du bureau du Sénat j'appelle chacun de
vous mes chers collègues à observé au
cours de nos échanges l'une des valeurs
essentielles du Sénat le respect qu'il
s'agisse du respect des uns et des
autres ou de celui du temps de parole et
si l'on pouvait s'écouter dans un
relatif silence ce serait magnifique
merci
la parole est au président Guillaume
gonta pour le groupe écologiste
solidarité territoire vous avez la
parole chers collègues
merci monsieur le président madame la
Première ministre j'avais prévu de vous
interpeller avec véhémence pour dénoncer
les manœuvres auxquelles ce livre votre
gouvernement et vos alliés pour empêcher
un vote en séance pénière de l'Assemblée
nationale invoque ne serait-ce que
symbolique sur le report de l'âge légal
de la retraite mais au regard des
événements consternants advenu ce matin
à l'Assemblée c'est avec une profonde
gravité que je m'adresse à vous madame
la Première ministre les droits des
oppositions politiques sont le fondement
même de la démocratie c'est à l'aune de
ces droits qu'on juge la qualité d'une
démocratie notre pays à tous les
échelons national ou locaux fait déjà
pas le figure avec une hypertrophie des
pouvoirs exécutifs et des assemblées
réduites à leur seule fonction
tribunicienne
pour tous nos partenaires européens
régime parlementaires rompus à la
négociation et à une certaine culture du
compromis notre régime politique est une
incongruité pour ne pas dire une
aberration dernière preuve en date de
culture politique très différente le
Premier ministre espagnol Pedro Sanchez
remet son mandat en jeu après avoir
perdu une élection municipale rien de
tel chez nous ou le gouvernement avance
en écrasant toute contestation devant
lui ce matin c'est bien plus que la
bataille de retraite qui est jouée à
l'Assemblée nationale en torpillant une
initiative parlementaire de l'opposition
en bafouant le droit d'amendement en
transformant le corset de l'article 40
en véritable étau vous créez un
précédent délétère qui menace de réduire
à néant le droit d'expression déjà
famélique des parlementaires madame la
Première ministre vous êtes une
démocrate vous l'avez clamé ici même en
juillet 2022 comment pouvez-vous tolérer
la dérive autoritaire dans laquelle le
président vous enferme
merci
la parole est à madame la Première
ministre merci monsieur le Président
Mesdames et Messieurs les Sénateurs
monsieur le Président Gontard
je suis souvent surprise d'entendre les
mêmes qui se disent défenseurs du
Parlement être les premiers à refuser
les règles
monsieur le Président Gontard
revenons-en au fait
l'examen de la réforme des retraites a
eu lieu avec 165 heures de débat
parlementaire elle a été votée par deux
fois par le Sénat et le Conseil
constitutionnel s'est prononcé très
clairement sur la conformité de
l'essentiel du texte à notre
Constitution et sur le rejet de deux
demandes de référendum d'initiative
partagée qui visait à l'abroger la
proposition de doigt dont vous parlez
qui fait actuellement l'objet d'un
examen par la commission des affaires
sociales de l'Assemblée nationale
aggraverait considérablement les charges
publiques et réduirait les recettes cela
controvient de façon évidente à
l'article 40 de notre Constitution
ce texte vous le savez monsieur le
Président est à anticonstitutionnel et
personne n'est dupe de la manœuvre qui
se joue et monsieur le Président Gaudin
vous appelez au respect du Parlement au
débat je vous je vous renvoie à ces
principes ce matin la commission des
affaires sociales de l'Assemblée
nationale à voter et à supprimer
l'article de la proposition de loi qui
visait à abroger la réforme des
retraites c'est un vote clair et
démocratique mais immédiatement après
laupes a répondu par l'obstruction avec
le dépôt de 3000 sous amendements pour
empêcher un vote final en commission
la réalité c'est que lorsque le résultat
d'un vote déplaît à la nupasse elle n'a
qu'une réponse l'obstruction de mon côté
je crois en notre Constitution et je
respecte le travail du Parlement alors
je souhaite que l'examen de la
proposition de loi puisse aller à son
terme dans de bonnes conditions et que
le contrôle de la recevabilité des
amendements puissent exercer normalement
dans la sérénité en somme je ne souhaite
qu'une chose le respect de nos règles et
du débat parlementaire je vous remercie
merci monsieur le Président Gontard 14
secondes madame la Première ministre
d'abord l'obstruction c'est vous toutes
les règles
madame le Premier ministre vous pouvez
entrer dans l'histoire en ouvrant une
page nouvelle de notre république
parlementaire vous seriez entrerez hélas
comme une Fossoyeuse de la démocratie
française
allez allez on se calme
la parole
la parole est maintenant madame Colette
mélo pour le groupe Les Indépendants
République et territoire vous avez la
parole chers collègues
[Applaudissements]
je ne serai pas là demain ce sont les
derniers mots de l'Insee présent
adressée par message à l'une de ses
camarades de classe le 12 mai dernier
l'Insee a décidé de mettre fin à ses
jours parce que la vie lui était devenue
insupportable 13 ans c'est normalement
l'âge de l'insouciance et de la joie de
vivre mais pour elle c'était l'enfer
parce qu'en groupe d'élèves l'art cela
est au collège et sur les réseaux
sociaux avec une violence inouïe
l'Insee vient ainsi compléter une liste
déjà beaucoup trop longue chaque année
près d'un million d'élèves sont victimes
de harcèlement scolaire et une vingtaine
d'entre eux commet l'irréparable madame
la ministre il faut que cela cesse avec
ma collègue Sabine vanegh qui vit ce
drame dans son département nous avons
remis notre rapport sénatorial sur ce
sujet à Monsieur
monsieur papendiye ministre de
l'éducation nationale
sera 35 préconisations autour de trois
priorités prévenir détecter les cas et
les traiter syst typiquement et sans
délai madame la ministre la situation
est urgente dès qu'en cas de harcèlement
apparaît c'est immédiatement que tous
les acteurs concernés doivent agir sans
minimiser les situations le
cyber-harcèlement fait son Stone œuvre
très rapidement en démultipliant les
conséquences graves l'enfant n'ayant
plus de répit même dans la sphère privée
le programme phare le mérite d'exister
mais il est malheureusement encore loin
d'être appliqué dans tous les
établissements malgré tous les efforts
déployés force est de constater que tout
n'est pas mis en oeuvre pour sauver les
enfants victimes de harcèlement dans le
cas de l'Insee la situation était
parfaitement connue dans l'établissement
mais quelle est cette jeune fille
a-t-elle reçu a-t-on vraiment tirer les
leçons des drames précédents madame la
ministre quelle mesure concrète
comptez-vous mettre à neuf immédiatement
merci
la parole est à madame Carole Grandjean
ministre délégué chargé de
l'enseignement de la formation
professionnelle vous avez la parole
madame la ministre merci monsieur le
Président Mesdames et Messieurs les
Sénateurs madame la sénatrice collecte
Colette mélo permettez-moi tout d'abord
d'adresser tout mon soutien et toutes
mes pensées à la famille de Lindsay nous
avons fait vous le savez de la lutte
contre le harcèlement une priorité et je
sais madame la sénatrice que nous
partageons ce combat et que vous êtes
impliqué sur ce sujet depuis longtemps
vous le savez nous concentrons tous nos
efforts pour lutter contre ce fléau
délictualisations du harcèlement
généralisation du plan phare dans toutes
les écoles primaires les collèges et dès
la rentrée 2023 et dans tous les lycées
formation de très grandes ampleur pour
tous les personnels à la prévention à la
détection et à la prise en charge du
harcèlement diffusion large des numéros
verts 36 18 et 36 19 et le ministre a
annoncé très récemment une procédure
spécifique décrets qui viendra en
juillet pour déplacer l'élève harceleur
comme l'avait proposé madame la
sénatrice Marie Mercier et pourtant oui
nous sommes de nouveau face à un drame
depuis le suicide de l'Insee à l'automne
dernier la mère de l'Insee avait
interpellé la direction de
l'établissement parce que l'INSEE était
victime de violence et de moqueries de
la part d'une autre élève de son
collègue cet élève avait fait l'objet
d'une exclusion de trois jours puis en
raison d'une récidive cet élève avait
été définitivement fin février de ce
collège ensuite il semblait que la
saison la situation s'est fait apaisée
mais le cyber-harcèlement que vous
évoquez a continué à l'abri des regards
et du contrôle des adultes et des
personnels enseignants c'est un sujet
fondamental sur lequel nous devons
continuer à travailler vous l'avez
largement souligné dans votre rapport
sur le harcèlement et ce n'est que trois
jours avant ce geste fatal que l'équipe
du collège a de nouveau été alerté pour
la situation de l'Insee mais cela n'a
pas suffi aujourd'hui des poursuites
pénales sont engagées quatre adolescents
et un adulte ont été mis en examen du
côté de l'éducation nationale le
ministre Istre a missionné l'inspection
générale pour mener une enquête
administrative sachez madame la
sénatrice que l'éducation nationale et
ses personnels mettent tout en oeuvre
pour éviter ces drames restons tous
solidaires et mobilisés contre ce fléau
je vous remercie madame la ministre la
parole est maintenant au président Bruno
retaillod pour le groupe les républicain
monsieur le Président mes chers
collègues c'est à vous madame la
Première ministre que je veux m'adresser
et à travers vous au président de la
République pour soutenir ici dans cette
émission une cause juste la cause d'un
petit peuple oublié un peuple qui a fait
l'objet il y a plus d'un siècle d'un
génocide et un peuple qui est
aujourd'hui au prises avec une tentative
d'épuration ethnique culturelle et
religieuse comme vous le savez depuis
près de six mois l'Azerbaïdjan bloque le
corridor de la Chine qui relie ce petit
territoire à l'Arménie et il fait donc
il transforme le ok Rabat en prison à
ciel ouvert dès le mois de février le 22
février la Cour de justice
internationale
assommer la serbaïdjan de lever le
blocus parce que le blocus met en danger
la vie de 120 000 Arméniens
donc 30000 enfants et c'est dans ces
conditions dans ce contexte que
l'Arménie défaite par la guerre des 44
jours le sabre sous la gorge sa
souveraineté désormais mise en jeu
menacé son intégrité territoriale aussi
pourrait envisager d'abandonner le
hautbarque dans ces conditions de
question et ces deux questions je
voudrais aussi associer dans un geste
transpartisan mon collègue Gilbert Luc
de vinasse qui préside le groupe
d'amitié franco-arménien première
question la France a toujours fait du
principe d'autodétermination des peuples
un principe cardinal pour le haut
carabaque comme pour toute sa politique
étrangère est-ce toujours le cas
deuxième question l'épuration ethnique
n'a jamais été aussi imminente question
qu'allez-vous faire pour la prévenir
pour l'empêcher
merci
la parole
la parole est à madame la Première
ministre merci monsieur le Président
Mesdames et Messieurs les Sénateurs
monsieur le sénateur Bruno Retailleau la
France avec ses partenaires et
pleinement engagé en faveur d'un
règlement durable du conflit entre
l'Arménie et l'Azerbaïdjan nous suivons
la situation avec la plus grande
attention et je sais votre mobilisation
sur ce sujet monsieur le Président la
ministre de l'Europe et des Affaires
étrangères s'est rendues dans la région
fin avril pour appeler les parties à
reprendre les discussions qui étaient
alors bloquées aujourd'hui sous l'égide
de l'Union européenne les négociations
de paix reprennent c'est un signal
encourageant et nous saluons le rôle
actif des États-Unis avec qui nous nous
coordonnons étroitement
monsieur le Président Retailleau notre
pays est engagé au plus haut niveau pour
la paix dans la région demain en marge
du sommet de la communauté politique
européenne de kishinao le président de
la République sera aux côtés du
chancelier Scholtz et de Charles Michel
pour une réunion avec le Premier
ministre arménien et le président
azerbaïdjanais il existe aujourd'hui une
voie pour la paix elle passe par la
reconnaissance mutuelle de la
souveraineté et de l'intégrité
territoriale des deux pays elle passe
par la délimitation de la frontière
commune et nous saluons à cet égard les
déclarations du Premier ministre
arménien Nicole pachinian dans ce
conflit la France n'oublie pas les
enjeux humanitaires et les conséquences
du blocage persistants du corridor de la
Chine nous n'avons eu de cesse de
rappeler la nécessité de mettre en œuvre
la décision de la Cour internationale de
justice du 22 février
plus particulièrement Monsieur le
Président Retailleau vous avez raison
d'évoquer les droits et garantis des
populations du haut-karaba qui doivent
pouvoir vivre en paix et en sécurité
vous pouvez compter sur le plein
engagement de la France pour continuer à
trouver des solutions durables et à la
paix dans la région je vous remercie
merci
monsieur le président
madame la Première ministre je sais
l'engagement de la France je sais je
reconnais l'engagement du président de
la République mais aujourd'hui nous
devons faire plus on doit faire plus
parce qu'on est à la veille d'une
tragédie on doit faire plus parce que on
le doit aux Arméniens à ce peuple frère
avec lequel nous partageons tant de
notre histoire des liens des liens
d'affection autant que des liens de
civilisation les maladies Charles
Aznavour les compositions de Michel
Legrand les films d'horriverny dont le
prénom était hashion et puis aussi
l'héroïsme de Manouchian qui bientôt
sans doute entrera par la grande porte
dans le potéon c'est la raison pour
laquelle nous devons faire encore
beaucoup plus merci nous avons des
devoirs et ça nous oblige à la première
fois
[Applaudissements]
il y a des questions il y a des
questions plus importantes peut-être
plus difficile
la parole est maintenant Madame Nathalie
Goulet pour le groupe Union centriste
vous avez la parole chers collègues
merci monsieur le Président voilà une
question difficile en effet vous avez
monsieur le ministre à tal vous avez
présenté hier votre plan de lutte contre
la fraude sociale je souhaite d'abord
vous remercier de convenir que la France
sociale est une réalité est une fraude
au finance publique à traiter comme tel
je fais ce rappel dans ton plus
volontiers que j'ai été traité de
menteuse dans cette émission et suppo du
rassemblement national par un ministre
votre majorité quand j'avais évoqué ce
sujet il y a quelques années quatre ans
plus tard de graves dysfonctionnements
demeure les fraudes sont évalués à 6 à 8
milliards frochettes basses la Cour des
comptes relève le taux important de
fraude documentaire et demande la
sécurisation d'immatriculation des
bénéficiaires faute de sécurisation
nous construisons vous construisez sur
du sable vous présentez des mesures
ponctuelles utiles mais vous abandonnez
la voix de la biométrie votez deux fois
ici au Sénat pour un système de fusion
entre la carte nationale d'identité et
la carte Vitale il y aurait en tenton
des voies divergentes au sein du
gouvernement pour cet outil dont la mise
en chantier prendra des années
pouvez-vous nous donner monsieur le
ministre le calendrier de la mise en
place de cette mesure et justifier votre
choix quand on connaît le temps qu'il
faut aujourd'hui en France pour avoir
une carte nationale d'identité merci
chers collègues la parole est un
monsieur Gabriel Attal ministre délégué
chargé des comptes publics vous avez la
parole monsieur le ministre merci
monsieur le Président Mesdames et
Messieurs les Sénateurs madame la
sénatrice Nathalie Goulet la lutte
contre la fraude sociale comme la lutte
contre la fraude fiscale et fondamentale
et quand on parle de lutter contre la
fraude sociale on parle tout simplement
de garder le contrôle sur notre modèle
social en reprenant le contrôle de ce
qu'on donne et à qui on le donne et je
voudrais commencer ma réponse en vous
remerciant vous avez travaillé depuis de
nombreuses années sur ce sujet vous avez
commis un rapport très important en 2019
avec ma collègue Carole Grandjean qui
était député à l'époque vous avez
participé au groupe de travail que j'ai
mis en place pour les laboration de ce
plan et plusieurs mesures de mon plan
viennent directement de propositions que
vous aviez émise j'en cite une à partir
du 1er juillet prochain nous ne
verserons plus d'allocations sociales
sur des comptes bancaires étrangers
c'est vous qui aviez fait cette
proposition et nous l'avons reprise vous
m'interrogez sur la carte Vitale
biométrique c'est une proposition
effectivement qui a été émise à
plusieurs reprises ici même nous avons
confié à l'Inspection générale des
affaires sociales et à l'Inspection
générale des finances une mission sur le
sujet le rapport a été remis à quelques
jours il est à votre disposition que dit
ce rapport un ça coûterait très cher 250
millions d'euros par an 2 il y a de
vrais freins juridiques et la CNIL
s'oppose à cette mesure 3 il y a des
freins pratiques les syndicats de
médecins dans le rapport disent même
qu'il s'y oppose et par ailleurs il y a
des fins pratiques aujourd'hui si vous
êtes cloué au lit que vous envoyez votre
proche cherchez vos médicaments à la
pharmacie si vous donnez donnez si vous
devez donner vos empreintes pour avoir
vos médicaments convenait que c'est
assez compliqué la mission
IGAS IGF recommande une autre voix de
sécurisation de la carte vitale en
faisant migrer la carte Vitale sur la
carte d'identité et c'est cette voix que
nous avons décidé de poursuivre ça
permettra de lutter davantage contre la
fraude à l'identité pour l'accès aux
soins dans notre pays par exemple à
travers du tourisme médical illégal nous
venons de lancer avec Gérald Darmanin et
François Brown une mission de
préfiguration pour déterminer le
calendrier et les modalités l'objectif
c'est d'aller vite mais évidemment qu'il
n'y ait pas de rupture dans l'accès aux
soins et aux droits pour les Français on
sait qu'il y a des difficultés
aujourd'hui pour renouveler ces titres
d'identité évidemment a-t-elle chantier
une telle bascule ne peut s'envisager
tant qu'on n'est pas revenu à la normale
même si la première ministre a annoncé
des moyens très importants pour qu'on
puisse revenir à des délais normaux donc
la mission de préfiguration sera lancée
et les propositions nous seront remises
merci Madame Golay
oui monsieur ministre vous savez qu'il y
a des mesures urgentes à faire vous
n'êtes pas sans ignorer qu'il n'y a
absolument pas de lien par exemple entre
le titre de séjour en France et les
droits sociaux vous avez quelqu'un dans
le titre de séjour expire et dont la
carte Vitale continue à fonctionner vous
avez aussi dans le rapport de la Cour
des comptes du 24 mai un chiffre un peu
étonnant de 58 millions de cartes
vitales active ce qui fait un surnombre
de 2 millions,6 alors que
l'administration a refusé de fournir à
la Cour des comptes le nombre de cartes
vitales actif par année de naissance qui
permettrait évidemment de contrôler
l'exactitude de ces cartes vous avez
également 44000 frauduleux vous avez un
fichier âgé de rêve pour les étrangers
remplacés par l'administration numérique
des étrangers en France qui ne
fonctionnent pas dans la cour dit que
c'est toujours pas opérationnel c'est à
dire que vous avez un certain nombre de
dysfonctionnements majeurs il faut
absolument les régler sinon votre plan
de sert à rien merci
[Applaudissements]
la parole
la parole est maintenant Monsieur Pierre
aux olias pour le groupe communiste
républicain citoyen et écologiste
monsieur le Président Madame la ministre
mes chers collègues comme tous les ans
presque 900 000 candidats ont soumis non
sans angoisse leur veut à la procédure
parcoursup comme tous les ans depuis
2018 nombreux sont ceux qui
s'interrogent sur les modalités les
critères et finalement l'intelligibilité
des conditions d'examen des dossiers par
certains établissements il est admis par
exemple que certaines filières réalisent
une première sélection des dossiers par
le seul usage d'un algorithme en outre
comme la révélé la Cour des comptes 20%
des commissions d'évaluation intègrent
dans leurs critères celui du lycée
d'origine certaines d'entre elles
pourraient même pondérer les notes du
contrôle continu par le rang de
classement de celui-ci ce qui pénalise
les élèves issus des établissements des
communes populaires notre groupe s'est
opposé à cette sélection qui est imposée
par le manque de place et le
sous-investissement chronique dans
l'université nous estimons à l'inverse
que la France à l'impériot devoir de
former plus d'ingénieurs plus de
techniciens et plus de diplômés de
l'université pour affronter les défis
climatiques technologiques et sociaux
mais dans l'immédiat considérons avec la
Commission européenne le Conseil
constitutionnel la Cour des comptes le
Défenseur des droits le comité d'éthique
de parcoursup et la commission de la
culture du Sénat il est impérieux de
présenter de façon explicite aux
candidats les procédures d'examen de
leur dossier certains établissements ont
usé et abusé d'une dérogation
législative discutable pour s'affranchir
de l'obligation faite à tous les agents
publics de rendre compte de son
administration comment pouvons-nous
reprocher au gafam et à Tik Tok de nous
cacher leurs algorithmes et accepter
l'opacité de ce parcoursup merci
monsieur le Président merci chers
collègues la parole est à Madame Sylvie
Retailleau ministre de l'Enseignement
supérieur et de la recherche
merci monsieur le Président Mesdames et
Messieurs les Sénateurs monsieur le
sénateur Ouzoulias alors d'abord je
voudrais vous dire combien je partage
avec vous cet ardente et je dis bien
ardente obligation de la transparence en
particulier quand il s'agit de l'avenir
de nos jeunes non pas parce que nos
enseignants profiteraient de l'opacité
pour pouvoir faire de la sélection
discriminante mais parce que la
transparente était la transparence
pardon est effectivement le levier un
levier pour accompagner en particulier
une meilleure orientation pour nos
jeunes mais aussi un levier pour rendre
les résultats de parcoursup plus
prévisible et donc diminuer le stress
pour les étudiants les élèves et leurs
familles alors depuis cinq ans que
faisons-nous et bien depuis cinq ans
l'amélioration continue de parcoursup
accompagne cette meilleure compréhension
de ces critères que vous appelez les
critères d'analyse de nos formations là
où il n'y avait rien nous avons expliqué
les attendus et oui nous avons rendu
il y a des enseignants qui travaillent
et je voudrais profiter de cette
occasion pour réinsister sur le travail
à tous niveaux de nos collègues je
finirai par dire que je sais que demain
s'ouvre la période pour nos étudiants
leurs familles de des résultats des
voeux et je voudrais leur dire que l'on
pense à eux que je pense à eux et que
tout est fait pour les accompagner merci
de penser à eux mais si possible dans
les deux minutes allez monsieur zoulias
une poignée de seconde poignée
merci monsieur le président madame la
ministre c'est un discours que j'entends
depuis 2018 il faudrait que maintenant
les choses changent l'université est un
service public il faut que votre
ministère se donne les moyens d'examiner
l'établissement établissement les
conditions dans lequel est réalisé cette
sélection merci monsieur le Président
merci
la parole est maintenant à Monsieur
Bernard buis pour le groupe
rassemblement des démocrates
progressistes et indépendant vous avez
la parole chers collègues merci monsieur
le président madame la Première ministre
mesdames et messieurs les ministres mes
chers collègues ma question s'adresse à
monsieur le ministre délégué chargé des
comptes publics lundi dernier vous avez
annoncé un vaste plan de lutte contre la
fraude sociale fraude multiforme évaluée
à 11 milliards d'euros qui rassemblent
aussi bien les cotisations sociales et
ludées la fraude aux prestation de santé
ou aux allocations sociales la fusion de
la carte Vitale avec la nouvelle carte
nationale d'identité mesure phare de
votre nouveau plan soulève plusieurs
interrogations tant sur sa mise en
oeuvre technique que sur la protection
des données déjà adoptée par plusieurs
pays européens dans la Suède le Portugal
ou la Belgique cette carte d'identité
électronique hybride permettrait
pourtant de renforcer les contrôles afin
de résorber les fraudes aux prestations
sociales
vous avancez également que dans 70% des
cas la fraude prestation de santé est à
l'initiative d'un professionnel par le
biais de surfacturation ou de
facturation d'actes fictifs l'an dernier
l'assurance maladie aurait ainsi détecté
300 millions d'euros de fraude vous
chiffrez également les arrêts maladie
dit de complaisance à 30 millions
d'euros entre 2017 et 2022 par
conséquent monsieur le ministre quels
sont les moyens que vous comptez
déployer pour détecter et lutter contre
ces prescriptions abusives merci pour
vos réponses la parole est à Monsieur
Gabriel Attal ministre délégué chargé
des comptes publics vous avez la parole
monsieur le ministre
merci monsieur le Président Mesdames et
Messieurs les Sénateurs monsieur le
sénateur Bernard buis oui vous avez
raison la lutte contre la fraude sociale
nécessite des moyens c'est la raison
pour laquelle j'ai annoncé un
renforcement des effectifs de contrôle
de l'ordre de 20% sur les 5 prochaines
années et un investissement massif dans
les systèmes d'information un milliard
d'euros pour moderniser les systèmes
d'information des caisses de sécurité
sociale sur les cinq années qui viennent
et il y a du chemin à parcourir j'étais
d'ailleurs c'est une recommandation qui
m'avait été faite en Belgique pour
rencontrer la Banque Carrefour de la
sécurité sociale on voit à quel point
leur système de données sont plus
performants j'étais hier à la Caisse
nationale d'allocations familiales on
m'a présenté un dossier tout à fait
édifiant dans le département du
Val-de-Marne 437 dossiers de
non-conformité identifiés il s'agissait
venant de Roumanie de personnes qui
avaient fait des fausses déclarations de
résidence des fausses déclarations de
salariés en France 8 millions d'euros de
préjudice sur le seul département du
Val-de-Marne via le numérique on doit
renforcer nos outils de détection et de
sanctions
investissement que j'ai annoncé sur la
question des de la fraude aux
prescription de santé que vous avez
évoqué c'est une réalité dans notre pays
il ne faut pas stigmatiser évidemment
l'écrasante majorité la quasi-totalité
des professionnels de santé font les
choses dans les règles et donne de leur
temps pour les autres et pour leur
passion mais il y a des fraudes l'an
dernier nous avons des conventionné 5
centres de santé notamment dentaires et
en ophtalmo qui surfacturait à
l'Assurance Maladie un certain nombre
d'actes qui en réalité n'avaient pas été
réalisé auprès de patients et donc j'ai
annoncé dans le plan un dispositif nous
allons faire en sorte que désormais
quand des Français des patients sortent
d'un centre de santé il reçoit
automatiquement par SMS la liste des
actes qui ont été
facturés à l'assurance maladie par le
centre de santé si ils se rendent compte
qu'il y a des actes qui ne l'auront pas
été réalisés ils pourront le signaler
avec un bouton de signalement ce qui
permettra à l'Assurance Maladie
d'orienter ces contrôles vers les
centres de santé ou les professionnels
pour lesquels il y a le plus de
suspicion de fraude voilà une mesure
parmi d'autres vous avez raison comme
vous je considère qu'il faut lutter
implacablement contre ses fraudes c'est
ce que nous faisons avec mes collègues
du gouvernement évidemment François
Brown Jean-Christophe Combes
singulièrement sur les prestations
sociales et l'assurance maladie je sais
pouvoir compter sur votre soutien
monsieur
[Applaudissements]
merci monsieur le ministre pour ses
moyens annoncés qui je l'espère et nous
l'espérons tous permettront de lutter
contre cette fraude sociale qui gangrène
notre pays
merci
la parole est maintenant Monsieur
Bernard Chaumier pour le groupe
socialiste écologiste et républicain
merci monsieur le Président avant de
poser ma question je voudrais saluer
madame la Première ministre pour ses
propos concernant pétains et le
rassemblement national
certes la politique ne se résume pas à
des positions morales mais celles-ci eu
égard à votre fonction et en particulier
à votre histoire personnelle mérite le
respect
ma question sera simple
un protocole thérapeutique a été mis en
oeuvre jusqu'au 31 décembre 2021 dans
notre pays portant sur 30 000 personnes
et en violation flagrante de la loi
protégeant les personnes soumises à une
recherche médicale c'est un fait inédit
et c'est un fait grave sans précédent
alors Monsieur le Ministre pourquoi une
telle inertie des pouvoirs publics face
à ce scandale pourquoi a-t-il fallu tant
de temps pour que ce déclenche enfin une
action et on l'a vu ce matin pourquoi
n'avez-vous pas pris les mesures
pour mettre fin à ce scandale et que
comptez-vous faire maintenant
merci
la parole est à Monsieur François Bonn
ministre de la Santé de la prévention
merci monsieur le Président Mesdames et
Messieurs les setter monsieur le
sénateur Bernard Chaumier nous parlons
ici d'une étude qui a été présentée en
préprint c'est-à-dire qui n'est pas
encore accepté par des revues
scientifiques heureusement devrais-je
dire qui porte 30 000 patients qui ont
été traités à l'Institut hospitalo
universitaire Marseille Méditerranée
pour dire les mots en dehors de tout
cadre d'expérimentation clinique en
dehors de tout cadre d'utilisation des
médicaments puisqu'ils étaient utilisés
hors
am autorisation de mise sur le marché
alors concernant cette cette institut en
plus médicament je tiens à le préciser
qui avait déjà fait la preuve de leur
inefficacité dans le cadre du traitement
de la coït 19
par rapport à cette situation une
enquête
IGAS igesr nous a rendu ses conclusions
en septembre 2022 à ma collègue Sylvie
retaillot et moi-même nous avons
immédiatement saisi le procureur de la
République de Marseille par le biais de
deux articles 40 devant la constatation
dans cette enquête de pratique aussi
bien managériale que de suivi des études
cliniques
inappropriée voir des viandes nous avons
dans les suites convoqué l'ensemble des
administrateurs de cette i hachu en leur
imposant la mise en place d'un plan de
redressement sur la base des conclusions
de cette enquête
IGAS igesr comme vous je déplore ce
nouvel épisode
inadmissible de cette affaire sachant
que la justice est en est en train de
suivre son cours comme vous avez pu le
constater avec moi dès ce matin devant
cette publication qui pourrait cette
proposition de publication qui pour moi
s'apparente a de la provocation nous
serons amenés et l'étude est en cours
avec les services juridiques apprendre
avec ma collègue Sylvie Retailleau pour
l'enseignement supérieur à la recherche
et moi-même toutes les mesures
nécessaires envers l'ensemble des
signatures de cet article je vous
remercie merci monsieur jaumier
monsieur ministre je pense que vous-même
avez conscience de la faiblesse de votre
réponse
il y a deux ans
alertes étaient déjà nombreuses les
rapports de la NSM les rapports de Ligas
et bien avant en 2015 l'Inserm quitté le
conseil d'administration de l'iachu
Méditerranée
café l'Université d'Aix-Marseille pour
mettre fin à ses dérives rien
qu'avez-vous fait messieurs les
ministres monsieur Véran vous étiez
ministre de la Santé vous n'avez pas
répondu à la question écrite que j'ai
déposée concernant les dérives de l'iagu
Madame Frédéric Vidal ministre de la
Recherche n'a pas répondu non plus à mes
questions et bien si l'ensemble des
institutions de notre pays et les
ministres se sont tu et on fait preuve
des faiblesses c'est peut-être parce que
le chef de l'État et allait couvrir de
sa chaleureuse immunité le patron de
l'IHU et c'est un dysfonctionnement
grave de nos institutions
[Applaudissements]
merci chers collègues la parole la
parole est maintenant Monsieur Bernard
fialer pour le groupe du Rassemblement
démocratique et social européen vous
avez la parole chers collègues merci
monsieur le Président ma question
s'adresse à madame la ministre de
l'Enseignement supérieur et de la
Recherche et une fois n'est pas de
coutume dans cette hémicycle je voudrais
parler d'amour
l'amour en général passe par l'amour de
la langue qui n'est ni nationaliste ni
conservateur mais qui exige des preuves
et des épreuves on ne fait pas n'importe
quoi avec la langue ces mots de Jacques
derida sont repris par le ministre de
l'éducation nationale Pape Ndiaye dans
le rapport au Parlement sur la langue
française
et pourtant le 10 mai 2023 à
l'Université Lyon 2 l'énoncé d'un examen
de licence en droit était rédigé dans un
langage inclusif excessif par son
intégrisme tous avec un Z à la place de
tous alt pour il ou elle mais aussi
professionnels appellent reconnu ouverte
aussi incompréhensible pourtant la
langue de la République et le français
essentiel à notre lien social pour
Michelin même l'identité de la France
c'est sa langue d'ailleurs à l'article 2
de la Constitution il est écrit la
langue de la République et le français
tous les citoyens ont ainsi le droit
démocratique garanti par la loi de
recevoir une information et de
s'exprimer dans leur langue la loi tout
bon affirme le droit aux Français pour
que l'ensemble de la société puisse se
comprendre et échanger et plus loin
d'ailleurs dans l'enseignement et la
recherche
c'est la langue de l'enseignement des
examens et concours ainsi que des thèses
et mémoires il s'agit de redonner à ce
cas de légal toute sa dimension
politique et d'agir pour maintenir son
efficacité ces mots sont dans le rapport
au Parlement la circulaire du 6 mai 2021
adressée au personnel de l'éducation
nationale énoncent les mêmes principes
pour les actes administratifs et les
pratiques d'enseignement madame la
ministre à l'université dans le respect
absolu de la liberté académique à
laquelle nous veillons tous que
pouvez-vous faire pour que la liberté de
penser d'innover de créer se fasse avec
le vocabulaire du dictionnaire officiel
de l'Académie française qui n'est pas
figée il mérite chaque année merci aux
nouveaux mots inscrit au journal d'une
caisse allez
[Applaudissements]
la parole est à Madame Sylvie Retailleau
ministre de l'enseignement supérieur à
la recherche
merci monsieur le Président Mesdames et
Messieurs les Sénateurs monsieur le
sénateur fieller merci beaucoup d'abord
pour votre question excusez-moi d'abord
je voudrais me permettre de compléter
juste pour rappeler deux éléments
importants sur le cas de normatif vous
en avez rappelé dans lequel nous nous
plaçons effectivement le premier c'est
la circulaire de 2017 du Premier
ministre de l'époque Édouard Philippe
sur les règles de féminisation qui
s'appliquent aux actes de nature
juridique et au texte administratif et
il le dit clairement dans un souci de
clarté et d'intelligibilité immédiate de
ces documents autant d'impératifs
auxquels je suis auquel nous sommes
également attachés donc en espace elle
ne s'applique pas au sujet d'examen
effectivement car dans l'enseignement
supérieur vous l'avez dit les
enseignants chercheurs sont entièrement
libres quand au sujet de leur cours mais
aussi de leur sujet d'examen et de leur
formulation l'université pas plus que le
ministère effectivement vous l'avez dit
sur la liberté académique n'exerce
directement de contrôle ni sur les
sujets ni sur le contenu pédagogique des
enseignements sauf en cas de propos
diffamatoires injurieux ou
discriminatoire donc juste pour appeler
dans le cas de Lyon sur lequel vous
m'interrogez effectivement l'épreuve en
droit de la famille proposait un choix
entre deux sujets qui permettait l'un
comme l'autre d'aborder une épreuve du
droit de la famille toutes deux traités
dans le cadre des enseignements
dispensés mais si l'un des deux sujets
proposés a été rédigé dans une forme
d'écriture dite inclusive et je n'en
dirai pas plus que ce que vous avez
décrit l'autre était effectivement
parfaitement classique cela étant si
votre question est encouragez-vous
l'usage de l'écriture dit inclusive dans
les sujets d'examens ou contrôle ou tout
document sous forme utilisant des points
médian ou des mots comme vous l'avez
prononcé ma réponse est clairement NON
et j'ai déjà eu l'occasion de le dire
il se trouve que je suis comme vous et
je croise beaucoup d'entre nous ici
afficher à notre belle langue il se
trouve que je suis aussi très attentif
aux questions de représentation c'est
pourquoi notre langue est suffisamment
riche pour s'exprimer sans véhiculer de
stéréotypes de genre et c'est pourquoi
nous développons les guides pour pouvoir
aider et pouvoir ne pas tomber dans
cette caricature par rapport aux examens
je vous remercie
vraiment orateur ou réponse des milliers
deux minutes et 2 minutes c'est pas deux
minutes 25 2 minutes 30 monsieur le
rapporteur général Jean-François Husson
à la parole pour le groupe les
républicain
madame la ministre 2022 année record en
matière de saisie de drogue mais 2022
forcée de le reconnaître c'est aussi une
montée inexorable de la violence liée au
trafic de drogue c'est aujourd'hui un
phénomène qui gangrène nos territoires
des grandes villes en passant par les
villes petites et moyennes mais même
aussi les territoires de haut qui
subissent aujourd'hui une spirale de
réglement de compte avec utilisation
d'armes à feu et bien sûr
fusillade Le Creusot Carpentras mais
aussi Orléans Chambéry Valence à mort et
dans mon département de
Meurthe-et-Moselle Villerupt
5 blessés dont trois blessés graves
madame la ministre comment l'État
répond-il aux appels à l'aide des
populations et des élus locaux face à
ces populations qui d'ailleurs sont
souvent sous l'emprise d'une forme de
terreur quels moyens déployer en termes
de surveillance de force de protection
et de sécurité et dans une zone police
comme celle de Villerupt quel plan
d'action concret comptez nous mettre en
œuvre
merci monsieur le rapporteur général la
parole est à Madame Dominique fort
ministre délégué chargé des
collectivités territoriales la ruralité
merci monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Rapporteur général
on partage le constat je vous demande de
bien vouloir excuser monsieur le
ministre de l'Intérieur et des premières
chair alternée en déplacement en
Nouvelle-Calédonie les villes que vous
avez citées dans votre département on
fait l'objet d'une fusillade j'étais
moi-même ici
en échange avec vous-même ou un de vos
collègues il y a 15 jours sur ce sujet
le ministre de l'Intérieur s'est mis en
capacité de se mobiliser immédiatement à
tout acte de violence liée à des trafics
de stupéfiants que cela soit dans les
quartiers des grandes villes où dans les
villes de taille moyenne un effort
significatif a été fait sur les renforts
policiers avec des ouvertures de poste
importantes lors du mouvement général
2023 + 11 postes ouverts pour la CSP de
Longwy dont dépend la commune de
Villerupt et plus 44 postes ouverts sur
le département du Meurthe-et-Moselle de
la Meurthe-et-Moselle ces efforts
s'inscrivent dans une dynamique plus
globale avec notamment une augmentation
de 8500 postes pour la police national
et la gendarmerie nationale sur cinq ans
grâce à la loop me par ailleurs une
concertation permanente avec les élus
locaux a été mise en place je vous
l'avais dit elle a eu lieu le 26 mai le
préfet reçu des élus demeure-et-moselle
afin d'échanger sur les différents axes
d'amélioration possible pour la sécurité
du territoire plusieurs propositions ont
été mises sur la table et vont faire
l'objet de nouveaux échanges avec les
élus lors d'une réunion place Beauvau le
5 juin l'ensemble des préfets je le
rappelle sont à la disposition des élus
pour adapter les dispositifs de sécurité
aux enjeux et notamment pour garantir la
mise en oeuvre des instances locales de
sécurité mais pour mettre en oeuvre les
financements de la vidéoprotection par
exemple je vous remercie merci monsieur
le rapporteur général
madame la ministre
finalement
j'assistais à la réunion du 26 mai mais
vous savez ce que vous venez de dire ça
fait plus d'une décennie qu'avec des
gouvernements successifs ces éléments
sont donnés mais finalement les
effectifs de police ne sont jamais à la
hauteur aujourd'hui à Villerupt Longwy
70 personnels là où il en faudrait 95 78
personnels où il en faudrait 95 annonce
du ministre avec effectivement des
arrivées mais c'est des arrivées de
personnes qui vont être remplacées par
autant de départ ça n'est pas si je vous
le dis ça n'est pas sérieux ce que nous
demandons aujourd'hui c'est de prendre
en compte la gravité de la situation
faut-il attendre des éléments encore
plus graves pour que aux côtés des
collectivités territoriales l'état
sachent mobiliser nous comptons sur
l'état merci monsieur le rapporteur
général la parole est maintenant Madame
Florence Béatrice compta pour le groupe
socialiste écologiste et République vous
avez la parole mes collègues merci
monsieur le président madame la ministre
mes chers collègues aujourd'hui partout
en France les enseignants manifestent le
refus du pacte que votre gouvernement
propose car le compte n'y est pas loin
de là est loin notamment de la promesse
d'Emmanuel Macron d'augmenter de 10 %
tous les enseignants en septembre
prochain l'éducation nationale vit une
véritable crise d'évocation le nombre
d'inscrits au concours en 2023 est en
aide baisse par rapport à 2021 et les
démissions ainsi que les ruptures
conventionnelles ont été multipliées par
5 la dégradation des conditions de
travail et du pouvoir d'achat en sont
les principales causes l'enjeu de cette
revalorisation aurait donc dû concerner
la partie socle c'est-à-dire
inconditionnel mais en réalité elle est
loin de rattraper les baisses de poire
d'achat de 15 à 25% de ces vins de ces
20 dernières années ni de rivaliser avec
nos voisins européens alors qu'un
enseignant débutait sa carrière à 2,2 SM
dans les années 90 il est aujourd'hui à
1,2 SMIC la rémunération des enseignants
est inférieure de 15% à ceux de l'OCDE
et je ne parle pas de nos voisins
allemands c'est donc cette enveloppe
socle qu'il faut avoir le courage
d'augmenter fortement et qu'il faut
traduire par un relèvement des points
d'indice et non par des primes quant à
la part d'augmentation d'échange de
mission supplémentaires elle n'est en
aucun cas une revalorisation salariale
c'est une provocation alors même que les
enseignants français travaillent
davantage que leurs homologues européens
avec davantage d'élèves ça contribuera à
dégrader encore les conditions
d'enseignement c'est le retour du
travail plus pour gagner plus allez vous
madame la ministre entendre les
enseignants et assurer à tous les
personnels une augmentation salariale
sans contrepartie qui rattrape les
pertes de pouvoir d'achat et qui
traduisent la considération de la nation
merci pour vos réponses la parole est à
madame Carole Grandjean ministre délégué
chargé de l'enseignement et la formation
professionnelle merci monsieur le
Président Mesdames et Messieurs les
Sénateurs madame la sénatrice Béatrice
blatix compta je vous rappelle que le
pacte enseignant est l'un des deux
volets que le gouvernement s'est engagé
à mettre en œuvre pour revaloriser le
métier d'enseignant ainsi que sa
rémunération pour rendre ce métier plus
attractif nous sommes face à un enjeu
crucial de mise à niveau des
rémunérations et de recrutement des
professeurs pour les prochaines années
sur la revalorisation inconditionnelle
qui va bénéficier donc à tous les
enseignants ainsi que monsieur le
Président de la République c'était
engagé à compter de la rentrée prochaine
tous les nouveaux professeurs titulaires
débuteront à plus de 2000 euros nets par
mois par ailleurs l'ensemble des
professeurs connaîtront une augmentation
de mensuel de leur rémunération nette de
95 allant jusqu'à plus de 200 euros ce
sont ainsi 850 000 professeurs et
personnels d'éducation et d'orientation
qui vont bénéficier de cette
augmentation cette revalorisation de
tous représente deux tiers de
l'enveloppe globale et inédite de 3
milliards d'euros inscrites au budget du
ministère à cette augmentation
inconditionnelle s'ajoutera uniquement
pour les professeurs volontaires
j'insiste sur ce point une rémunération
supplémentaire en contrepartie de
mission complémentaires chaque mission
sera indemnisée de 250 euros brut par an
un professeur pouvant choisir plusieurs
missions ainsi par exemple un professeur
qui choisira trois missions sera
rémunéré en plus de sa rémunération de
base à hauteur de 3750 euros brut par an
pour le cas des lycées professionnels
pour lesquels j'ai engagé une réforme
d'ampleur la rémunération des
professeurs volontaires pour ce pacte
sera un forfait annuel de 7500 euros
brut l'objectif est donc clair il ne
s'agit d'une demande imposée à toutes un
quelconque travaillait plus pour gagner
plus mais bien pour toutes les missions
complémentaires de un service public de
l'éducation plus efficace pour nos
élèves et de valoriser l'engagement des
enseignants je vous remercie merci
Madame l'adresse Conca une dizaine de
secondes
n'avait pas pris la mesure de la
situation nos enseignants méritent une
juste revalorisation salariale votre
réforme n'est pas à la hauteur des
enjeux elle va au contraire des
organiser notre système scolaire et
dégrader les conditions de travail merci
la parole est maintenant monsieur
Étienne blanc pour le groupe l'air
républicain merci monsieur le président
et madame la Première ministre et le
tribunal administratif de Grenoble le 11
mai a rendu une décision par laquelle il
annule le règlement de l'Institut des
langues de l'Université de Grenoble
parce que il fut écrit en écriture
inclusive utilisant à la fois le point
médian et le langage de gens
le tribunal l'explique clairement que ce
règlement est illisible et qu'en tout
cas il n'est pas écrit en français et il
n'est pas conforme à la Constitution
quelques jours après et dans une
interview Figaro Madame la Ministre de
l'Enseignement supérieur et de la
recherche qui est quand même en charge
de former nos élites
explique que finalement au titre des
libertés académiques on peut accepter
l'écriture inclusive alors madame la
Première ministre mais qui faut-il
croire le président de la République
qui a vu l'air Cauterets le temple de
l'écriture et de la langue française
avait affirmé que c'était un véritable
trésor qui fallait le protéger où
faut-il croire aux ministres qui
s'explique à l'envie que finalement on
peut accepter l'écriture inclusive qui
détruit la langue française merci
[Applaudissements]
pour vos réponses
pour vos réponses la parole est à Madame
Sylvie Retailleau ministre de
l'Enseignement supérieur et de la
Recherche merci monsieur
le sénateur blanc alors merci déjà de me
donner l'occasion de repréciser je sais
excusez-moi mais il y a merci Monsieur
sénateur de me donner le l'occasion de
préciser non comme je l'ai dit tout à
l'heure je ne suis pas pour
l'utilisation de l'écriture inclusive je
crois que vous avez et c'est pour ça que
ça me donne l'occasion quand on explique
de l'écriture exclusive avec des points
médian ou bien comme ça a été redit tout
à l'heure des exemples qui sont proches
non respect de la langue française mais
quand on dit cher tout et tous ce que
j'appelais l'expression et c'est
d'inclure l'ensemble c'est très
différent de l'inclature inclusive et
cela me donne l'occasion et je vous en
remercie de leur expliquer tout d'abord
monsieur sénateur je vous sais très
attaché aux libertés académiques dont on
parle aussi ici par rapport au sujet de
Lyon puisque effectivement le cas de
Grenoble tombe sous la coupe de la
circulaire et donc le tribunal
administratif a rendu vous le savez vous
l'avez rappelé dans le cadre de vos
travaux avec le sénateur gâteau lin sur
les ingérences étrangères on ne peut pas
être pour la liberté académique
l'autonomie des universités et fustigés
continuellement le ministère pour qu'il
intervienne à tout bout de champ pour
régir le contenu de ce que propose les
enseignants et les enseignants
chercheurs je voudrais juste rappeler
pourquoi cette liberté académique est
importante ce qui nous empêche pas de
donner effectivement des consignes
claires en nous appuyant sur les
circulaires qui existent pour pouvoir
respecter la langue française comme on
se doit de la respecter et avoir des
sujets des examens et en enseignement au
niveau d'une langue intelligible et
claire ce qui est important je vous
rejoins là dessus pour l'enseignement de
tous nos étudiants je vous remercie
merci Monsieur blanc oui merci le moins
qu'on puisse dire madame la ministre
c'est que votre réponse est quelque peu
ambigu en tout cas elle n'est pas claire
et d'abord vous ne répondez pas aux
dispositif au jugement du tribunal de
Grenoble sur l'inintelligibilité et
surtout sur le problème constitutionnel
et puis vous ne répondez pas à
l'Académie française qui en matière
d'écluses d'écriture inclusive parle
d'un péril mortifère et elle parle d'une
aberration alors Camus disait tout le
malheur des hommes provient du fait
qu'il ne tienne pas un langage clair et
bien moi j'invite aujourd'hui le
gouvernement à tenir un langage clair
l'écriture inclusive c'est oui ou c'est
non si c'est non
d'ici enfin que tout texte de quelques
natures qu'il soit écrit en un écriture
inclusive est nul de plein droit et là
vous tiendrez un langage clair merci
la parole
là par
et maintenant à Monsieur Michel Cannet
pour le groupe Union centriste
merci merci monsieur le président madame
la Première ministre mesdames et
messieurs les ministres chers collègues
la première ministre a présenté voilà 10
jours
les pistes du gouvernement concernant la
transition écologique et elle a été
annoncé qu'un plan d'action serait
proposé à la fin Johan bien entendu
monsieur le Président nous sommes tous
attachés à la transition écologique et
en particulier pour aller vers une
énergie de plus en plus décarbonée mais
il nous semble important de tenir compte
à la fois des réalités économiques à la
fois des réalités territoriales des
réalités sociales ainsi nous sommes
particulièrement inquiets concernant le
projet d'interdiction d'installation de
chaudière à gaz parce qu'il est
transpararé dans les propos que cela
pourrait survenir or aujourd'hui plus
d'un logement sur quatre a comme mode de
d'énergie le gaz il est donc important
de tenir compte de cela et je souhaitais
connaître les intentions réelles du
gouvernement à cet égard
pour vos réponses la parole est à Madame
Agnès panière une hachée ministre de la
transition énergétique
monsieur le Président Mesdames et
Messieurs
les dames et messieurs les sénateurs
monsieur le sénateur Canivet le
président de la République nous a fixé
un objectif clair en matière de
transition énergétique être le premier
pays industriel assortir des énergies
fossiles et c'est une condition si nous
voulons atteindre la neutralité
climatique d'ici 2050 ce défi est
immense vous le savez nous ne pouvons le
réussir que grâce à la mobilisation de
chacun d'entre nous c'est pourquoi le
gouvernement travaille sous l'égide de
la première ministre à des feuilles de
route secteur par secteur pour
décarboner et notamment évidemment sur
le secteur du bâtiment et du logement et
vous le savez dans le bâtiment 47% des
émissions de CO2 si on regarde l'usage
du bâtiment ce sont ces liés au
chauffage au gaz alors on le sait
réduire les énergies fossiles dans ses
logements c'est réduire la facture c'est
réduire notre dépendance à des énergies
importées et donc augmenter notre
souveraineté et c'est agir contre le dé
climatique ce mouvement il n'est pas
nouveau puisque les dispositifs appris
brenoff permettent aujourd'hui déjà
d'accompagner les Français qui
souhaitent changer de chaudière et avoir
une chaudière non fossile et nous avons
également pris une mesure importante qui
est de ne pas permettre l'installation
de chauffage au gaz dans les bâtiments
neufs nous allons continuer à travailler
c'est tout l'objet de la concertation
que je vais lancer avec mes collègues
Christophe Béchu et Olivier Klein pour
faire en sorte de trouver par
anticipation et en nous projetant dans
la durée les meilleures solutions
permettant à la fois de construire les
filières alternatives à au chauffage à
gaz et vous savez que nous avons des
positions non négligeables sur les
pompes à chaleur par exemple mais
également de faire en sorte que les
Français ou qu'ils soient sur le
territoire et quel que soit leur type de
logement puisse être accompagnés dans
l'évolution de leur mode de chauffage et
au final pour tenir notre trajectoire de
baisse de gaz et émission de de à effet
de serre je sais que vous y êtes
clairement attachés nous lancerons donc
prochainement cette concertation et vous
pouvez compter sur nous pour le faire de
manière pragmatique éduquer mais pour ne
pas perdre de vue l'ambition climatique
que nous portons
monsieur Canet et lui seul monsieur
Canet merci monsieur le Président je
comprends et je partage cette ambition
d'économie des carbonée madame la
ministre mais je dois rendre le
gouvernement attentif au fait que nous
ne pouvons nous contenter d'une seule
source d'énergie je veux dire par là
qu'il faut qu'il y ait un mix
énergétique qui permettent d'assurer la
réelle souveraineté de notre pays en
s’est aperçu cet hiver que de se reposer
sur la seule situation de l'électricité
pour tous les usages nous amener à
quelques déconvenues et donc il importe
que dès à présent nous prenions bien
cela en compte et sur les territoires
ruraux en particulier on sait bien que
nous avons des foyers qui ont des moyens
très limités et on sait que la
production de gaz renouvelable peut
apporter à la fois des solutions
économiques à notre pays mais aussi des
solutions intelligentes pour
l'énergie de nos territoires donc soyons
attentifs à cela
merci chers collègues la parole est
maintenant madame Christina plucher pour
le groupe les républicains
merci
merci monsieur le président madame la
ministre mes chers collègues aujourd'hui
l'actualité de mon département l'heure
me conduit à évoquer l'exclusion des
enfants porteurs de handicap à prise en
charge complète en l'occurrence certains
cas d'autisme auquel la République ne
garantit pas un droit décent à
l'éducation d'ailleurs le 17 avril la
France a été condamnée par le Comité des
droits sociaux du Conseil de l'Europe
pourtant de nombreux budgets ont été mis
sur la table depuis des années le virage
de l'inclusion a été engagé et tant
mieux mais je crains madame la ministre
qu'on soit passé d'une extrême à l'autre
inclure qu'on l'a prise en charge est
compliquée ce n'est pas laissé ses
enfants à domicile pendant plusieurs
années avec un saupoudrage
d'intervenants ponctuels attend très
partiel générant la rupture
professionnelle d'un parent et sa
précarité économique inclure ce n'est
pas hyper trop fier les moyens à louer à
la commitologie et à la concertation aux
dépens de la création effective de place
en structure communication adaptées
inclure c'est comprendre que le milieu
dit protégé à toute sa place parmi les
propositions comme lieu d'expertise au
bénéfice des enfants dont la prise en
charge est la plus complexe alors madame
la ministre qu'avez-vous prévu pour
résorber le problème de l'embouteillage
dans les instituts médicaux-éducatifs
pour la rentrée prochaine quelle
solution digne allez vous proposer à ses
parents désespérés qui en sont même à se
mettre en grève de la fin et qu'elle
voit de financement allez vous mettre en
oeuvre pour sortir des éternels effets
d'annonce et chez enfin les budgets vers
la création de place supplémentaires
madame la mise ses enfants ne sont pas
des enfants de la République à temps
partiel ils ont comme les autres le
droit à une éducation à temps complet
merci
pour vos réponses la parole est à Madame
Geneviève Darius sec ministre délégué
chargé des personnes handicapées
merci monsieur le Président Mesdames les
sénatrices messieurs les sénateurs
madame la sénatrice puchez je vous
remercie de votre question elle va me
permettre de faire un point
effectivement j'ai rencontré aujourd'hui
le maire de pose dans votre département
et il a des préoccupations très
légitimes de papa mais il a aussi porté
il porte aussi le sujet plus global de
famille qui sont comme lui dans des
impasses
[Musique]
aujourd'hui les cols inclusives c'est
430000 enfants inclus dans l'école de la
République mais les IME c'est 1140e sur
notre territoire national pour 71000
places les places animées n'ont jamais
été supprimés n'ont jamais été diminué
et ont toujours continué à évoluer il
faut savoir que sur ces 71000 places à
nieme il y a de façon anormale 10 000
places occupées par des adultes sous
amendement Creton qui reste dans ses ime
notre première mission doit être avec
les départements chaque département de
travailler efficacement et concrètement
à faire en sorte de trouver des
solutions différentes pour ces adultes
afin de redonner de la capacité à saisir
eux de pouvoir accueillir des enfants
car la place des enfants c'est dans des
établissements pour enfants
deuxièmement il y a des territoires dans
notre pays qui sont en manque de
solutions et ça nous les avons bien
identifié il y a une vingtaine de
département environ et nous allons
travailler prioritairement à proposer
des nouvelles solutions des nouvelles
places ou solutions dans ces
départements et enfin il y a des
handicaps particuliers et complexes
comme vous le disiez qui nécessite aussi
de porter des solutions nouvelles la
Conférence nationale du handicap a donné
l'occasion aux présidents de la
République de s'engager sur 50 nouvelles
50 000 pardon nouvelle place et
solutions pour la France entière et
c'est dans ce contexte là que nous
allons déployer cela c'est un effort
majeur 2 millions d'euros de plus sur
nos budgets et que nous déploierons sur
les cinq prochaines années merci Madame
Truchet
comme vous le dites c'est vrai qu'il y a
il manque des places alors j'envie j'ai
envie de vous dire donc place au concret
augmentons avec plus de souplesse les
capacités d'écueil soient structures par
structure ou ou même en permettant des
projets innovants parce que c'est vrai
que ces enfants qui sont tellement
vulnérables ils méritent une attention
toute particulière de la nation
merci cher collègue la parole est
maintenant monsieur Jean-Jacques Lauzac
pour le groupe socialiste écologiste et
République
[Applaudissements]
monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues ma question
s'adresse à Madame la Ministre des
Sports et des Jeux olympiques et
paralympiques en effet la Coupe du monde
de football féminin va se dérouler de 20
juillet au 20 août prochain or à ce jour
aucun accord n'a été trouvé avec les
diffuseurs éventuels pour sa
retransmission TV en France l'appel
d'offres concernée n'est toujours pas
abouti cette réalité devient
préoccupante appréciation confirmée par
le président de la FIFA organisatrice de
l'événement je cite si les offres
continuent à ne pas être équitables nous
serons contraint de ne pas diffuser la
Coupe du Monde féminine dans les cinq
grands pays européens je précise que les
revenus ainsi générés sont redistribués
intégralement pour le développement du
sport féminin et que les chaînes
françaises étaient engagées à davantage
favoriser le sport féminin l'enjeu de la
Coupe du Monde 2023 est capitale et la
non retransmission d'une match de notre
équipe nationale l'une des meilleures
elle fait partie du top 5 mondial serait
d'autant plus incombréhensible que la
dernière édition
organiser en France en 2019 et avait
remporté un succès dépassant toutes les
prévisions ainsi le match de quart de
finale avait-il avait-il connu le score
d'audience le plus élevé de toute
l'année 2019 pour TF1 et 4 ans plus tard
cette équipe serait laissée à l'abandon
par tous les diffuseurs potentiels avec
la loi du 2 mars 2022 visa démocratisé
le sport le Parlement a voté la
possibilité de créer une société
commerciale visage et républicaissement
des droits audiovisuels du sport
professionnel pour l'heure seul le
football est concerné il serait
paradoxal que parallèlement à cette
démarche la dimension féminine de cette
activité soit exclue des bénéfices
financiers escomptés lors d'un grand
événement international il y va
symboliquement de la promotion de
l'affirmation et du financement du sport
féminin l'enjeu et la lutte contre
toutes les formes de discrimination
faisant obstacles à l'émancipation de la
femme par le sport pouvez-vous indiquer
si à ce stade il y a lieu de rester
optimiste quant à ces retransmissions en
un mot la France sera-t-elle de Coupe du
Monde Féminine enfin le décret de
décembre 2004 listant les 21 événements
d'importance majeurs doit-il être élargi
à l'ensemble des matchs des équipes de
France de football et de rugby masculine
et féminines et si oui tant qu'elle
délai merci au revoir la parole est à
Monsieur Olivier Véran ministre délégué
chargé du renouveau démocratique
porte-parole du gouvernement merci
monsieur le Président Mesdames et
Messieurs les Sénateurs c'est natrices
vous l'avez dit en 2019 nous étions 12
millions de téléspectateurs pour
encourager l'équipe de France féminine
de football face au Brésil 12 millions
ça crée beaucoup de vocations et on a
besoin de montrer ces images de
sportives de haute compétition pour
donner envie aussi à notre jeunesse de
faire du sport qu'elle soit féminine ou
masculine il y aura dans 50 jours le
début de la Coupe du Monde féminine de
football à nouveau c'est du côté je
crois de l'Australie et la
Nouvelle-Zélande pour ne pas dire de
bêtises et nous voulons évidemment que
les Françaises les Français puissent
regarder la France nous l'espérons au
final le 20 août prochain de cette Coupe
du Monde allez initiative de la France
mais aussi de l'Allemagne de l'Italie de
l'Espagne de l'Angleterre au temps de
pays européens passionnés de football
comme chacun sait la ministre des sports
dont j'excuse l'absence parce qu'elle
est actuellement dans un événement des j
moins 100 de la Coupe du monde de rugby
cette fois-ci la mise à sport Amélie ou
des accastera a rédigé un communiqué
commun avec ses homologues européens à
destination de la FIFA des annonceurs
pour dire sa volonté qu'un accord puisse
être trouvé de manière à ce que la Coupe
du Monde féminine de football puisse
bien être diffusé dans notre pays ainsi
que dans l'ensemble des pays européens
passionnés de football elle a pris
l'engagement elle l'a dit ce matin qu'il
une solution sera trouvée pour ce faire
par ailleurs monsieur le sénateur
j'insiste avec vous sur la nécessité de
diffuser du sport féminin aujourd'hui
c'est que 5% du sport diffusé sur la
télévision qui concerne le sport féminin
or le sport féminin est un sport de
qualité d'excellence et qui fait rêver
je vous remercie
merci Monsieur le Ministre la parole est
maintenant Madame Florence lassarade
pour le groupe les républicain merci
monsieur le Président Monsieur
le meleg
fermeture temporaire des services
d'urgence et de maternité se multiplient
en raison des difficultés de recrutement
médical ainsi en l'espace d'un mois le
service des urgences du centre
hospitalier de Sainte-Foy-la-Grande a
été fermée à 4 prises ce qui correspond
à une durée de 17 jours au total les
services d'urgence d'Arcachon et la
maternité de Langon ne sont pas buz
épargnés ces fermetures temporaires ne
se limitent pas au département de la
Gironde et touche l'ensemble du
territoire ces arrêts sont beaucoup plus
prégnants sur les territoires ruraux on
cause le manque de médecin de médecins
accrue par la mise en oeuvre de la loi
risques qui plafonne la rémunération des
médecins intérimaires or on constate
déjà 14000 décès supplémentaires par an
dans les zones rurales par rapport aux
villes par ailleurs de 2012 à 2019 on
observe une augmentation de 7% de la
mortalité infantile ainsi en l'espace
d'une décennie la France est passée du
deuxième au 25e rang européen
cette dégradation alarmante de notre
système de santé est inacceptable votre
gouvernement culpabilise les médecins en
laissant penser qu'ils sont responsables
de la situation ce matin j'ai appris que
la chef de service d'une de ces
structures en poste de plus de depuis
plus de 30 ans vient de faire une
tentative de suicide ce que vivent les
médecins est inhumain ils ne sont pas là
pour pallier les insuffisances du
système c'est votre responsabilité nous
connaissons des difficultés de
recrutement et de fidélisation des
praticiens hospitaliers en raison d'un
manque d'attractivité le constat est
sans appel aujourd'hui 30% des postes de
praticien hospitalier sont vacances et
du jamais vu monsieur le ministre il
faut remettre de l'attractivité pour la
médecine hospitalière nous avons le
devoir collectif de renverser cette
situation quelle solution pérenne
proposez-vous pour pallier les
difficultés de recrutement médical et
éviter la multiplication des fermetures
temporaires des services d'urgence et
des maternités
merci pour vos réponses la parole est à
Monsieur François borne ministre de la
Santé de la prévention merci monsieur le
Président Mesdames et Messieurs les
Sénateurs madame la sénatrice la Sarrade
effectivement les difficultés de notre
système de santé sont accusés dans les
services avec plus forte pénibilité en
particulier la pénibilité des gardes de
nuit donc faites bien de signifier les
services d'urgence et les maternités des
maternités cumulant en plus la
difficulté d'avoir trois spécialités
pour pouvoir assurer un fonctionnement
en maternité les gynécovstétriciens
anesthésiteraient animateurs et pédiatre
ces difficultés sont connues ces
difficultés ne sont pas nouvelles et je
ne peux pas vous laisser dire que
l'intérim en tout cas la
justifier lutte contre les dérives de
l'intérim médical qui est en train
d'assécher complètement nos hôpitaux
soit responsables de la situation
actuelle nous avons au contraire passé
ces difficultés pendant le mois d'avril
et le mois de mai et maintenant nous
avons la visibilité de ce qui se passe
réellement sur notre territoire comme je
m'y étais en nous trouvons des solutions
certes alternatives sur l'ensemble des
territoires pour qu'il n'y ait pas de
difficultés dans le cadre des parcours
de soins je vous rejoins lorsque vous
dites que ces difficultés ne sont pas
nouvelles et sont anciennes elles sont
en particulier du à des difficultés du
nombre de personnels médical je ne
rappellerai pas le numérique clausus
parce que forte heureusement le
gouvernement précédent a levé cette
barrière du numérique qui quoi qu'on en
dise nous permet aujourd'hui d'avoir 15%
de médecins en plus qui vont sortir de
nos facultés dans quelques années la
solution elle est globalement sur trois
principes un principe d'éthique c'est
comme ça qu'on reconstruit notre système
et c'est ça la lutte contre les dérives
de l'intérim et d'autres luttes
financière un principe d'équipe à
l'échelle de l'équipe de chaque service
que l'on peut reconstruire un principe
de territoire la responsabilité
territoriale a été mise en place au
niveau des hôpitaux pendant ces travaux
contre les dérives de l'intérim et la
fonctionner elle fonctionne encore pour
assurer la meilleure réponse à nos
concitoyens et je profite des dernières
secondes pour préciser qu'en ce qui qui
concerne l'aide médicale urgente
c'est-à-dire des urgences vitales qui
est un sujet que je connais bien
celle-ci reste garantie sur l'ensemble
du territoire national je vous remercie
merci Madame la Sarah 10 secondes
monsieur le ministre vous ne répondez
pas à ma question le président de la
République promet aux Français le
désengorgement des urgences fin 2024
mais tant que les personnels soignants
ne sont pas rémunérés à hauteur de leur
engagement de leur responsabilité le
désengorgement des urgences restera une
belle promesse merci
la parole est maintenant madame Lana
tétouani pour le groupe Union centriste
[Applaudissements]
la première ministre mesdames et
messieurs les ministres chers collègues
ma question sera très monsieur le
ministre de l'Intérieur et des Outre-mer
monsieur le ministre depuis quelques
mois je suis continuellement interpellé
par mon compatriotes polynésien sur les
délais d'obtention d'un passeport
dans un territoire comme le mien ainsi
pour tous ceux situés hors zone
européenne détenir un passeport à jour
est une condition essentielle pour se
déplacer mais l'obtenir relève
aujourd'hui du parcours du combattant
nous connaissons aussi les difficultés
à l'échelon national mais pour nos
citoyens ultramarins situés si loin du
centre dédié allez laboration des
passeports ma question est la suivante
quelle mesure combien de t-il d'adopter
d'adapter pour des délais plus
raisonnables dans l'obtention et la
cheminement de passeport en outre-mer
merci
pour vos réponses la parole de Madame
Dominique Faure ministre délégué chargé
des collectivités territoriales de la
réalité merci monsieur le Président
Mesdames et Messieurs les Sénateurs
madame la sénatrice et Lana tétouani je
demande de bien vouloir excuser monsieur
le ministre de l'intérieur des votre
mère qui d'ailleurs est un autre mère
pour vous dire et vous le savez que les
délais de délivrance des passeports et
des cartes d'identités à augmenter
énormément avec l'augmentation du nombre
de demandes on est passé de 9 millions
en 2021 à 12 millions 2022 à 15 millions
actuellement donc nous mettons des
moyens très importants nous avons encore
renforcé ces moyens pour raccourcir ces
délais à la demande de Madame la
première ministre il y a exactement un
mois mais
les délais en Polynésie sont
particulièrement
satisfaisant ils sont
alors pourquoi je suis sûr je suis sûr
parce que on est à 30 jours chez vous on
est à 30 jours chez vous on est encore
en moyenne à 50 jours on était à 70
jours il y a 2 mois donc les délais
moyen baisse mais les délais en
Polynésie vous avez 18 dispositifs de
recueil et en étant en train d'en mettre
un 19e donc les délaiss soient trop
longs et même un mois vous trouviez que
ce soit trop long je suis d'accord avec
vous nous y travaillons nous portons
l'objectif de les baisser très
significativement d'ici l'été cependant
je vous demande d'entendre que
les collectivités locales et le préfet
en Polynésie fait un travail remarquable
qui fait que le délai est très bas merci
madame tais-toi nuit je suis sûr que
vous allez dire votre ravissement
allez-y madame la fenêtre madame la
ministre je vous remercie mais je vais
être gentille aujourd'hui je vous
pardonnerai je vous excuserai mais pas
la méconnaissance mais totale
de ce qui se passe dans nos
collectivités
ultramarines si je m'exprime aujourd'hui
c'est parce que il y a un problème si
tout allait bien je me tirer mais c'est
pas le cas ce n'est pas le
parce que là où je vous interpelle
aujourd'hui à l'approche des grandes
vacances scolaires pour tous ceux et
tous celles qui veulent rentrer dans nos
collectivités il y aura la rentrée
universitaire au mois de septembre pour
tous nos étudiants qui viendront
poursuivre les études ici
en France on fait quoi non on dit plus
métropole on dit hexagone aujourd'hui
d'après l'Assemblée nationale mais on
fait quoi
les services de l'État les services du
haut-commissaire précisément en
Polynésie française quand les appels
qu'est-ce qui nous disent qu'est-ce
qu'ils disent ah là c'est exclusive
excusez-nous madame martinatrice il y a
trop de demandes on y peut rien ils font
attendre mais c'est à bureau d'entendre
ça en 2023
c'est environ
[Musique]
madame la Première ministre mesdames et
messieurs les ministres mes chers
collègues les prochaines questions
d'actualité au Gouvernement auront lieu
le mercredi 7 juin à 15h je vais
suspendre la séance elle sera reprise à
16h30 pour le débat sur le bilan de
l'application des lois la séance est
suspendue
[Musique]
voilà pour cette séance deux questions
d'actualité du Sénat au gouvernement on
va maintenant passer aux réactions à
cette séance et je suis actuellement
avec Yann chanterelle bonjour bonjour
vous êtes aussi un tort socialiste des
Français établir de France une séance de
questions actualités qui a commencé par
année change à s'étendu entre le
président du groupe écologiste au
sénager et la première ministre et
Isabelle borne autour et bien de la
proposition de loi à l'Assemblée
nationale du groupe lyaute pour abroger
la réforme des retraites la première
ministre est restée ferme elle l'a dit
il faut combattre ce texte car selon
elle il est inconstitutionnel sur le
plan financier votre réaction à cette
réponse de la première ministre bah ma
réaction c'est comme depuis le début de
l'étude de ce du texte qui a été adopté
c'est véritablement le coup de force
permanent une forme de déni démocratique
puisque il y a jamais eu de vote réel à
l'Assemblée nationale et on voit bien
que le gouvernement fait tout ce qui
peut il utilise tous les artifices voir
d'ailleurs à la limite de la légalité
parce que ce qui se passe à l'heure
actuelle au sein de la commission des
affaires sociales et particulièrement
inquiétant véritable coup de force où
ils étudie même pas les amendements qui
sont proposés par par l'opposition et
donc ce qu'on comprend c'est surtout que
ce gouvernement a peur d'un vote
pourquoi ils ont peur d'un vote parce
qu'ils vont le perdre ils savent qu'il y
a pas de majorité au Parlement sur ce
texte c'est ça qui sont en train de
démontrer en ne voulant pas que le
Parlement discute de ce texte et vote
surtout réellement sur ce texte vous
parlez de code force et pourtant un
gouvernement s'appuie sur la
constitution l'article 40 sur la
recevabilité financière des propositions
de loi elles ne peuvent pas aggraver la
charge publique or cette proposition loi
du groupe biote et bien elle aggrave la
charge publique de 15 milliards d'euros
c'est quand même assez assez conséquent
alors après il y a aussi le président de
la commission des finances qui lui est
jugeant et qui lui a donné son feu vert
donc on a vraiment un problème aussi
d'ordre institutionnel quelque part
derrière ça de pratique politique de
quoi a peur le gouvernement de laisser
les parlementaires faire leur travail et
de voter sur un texte parce que vous
dites ça n'est pas valable au motif de
l'article 40 mais il y a plein de
propositions de loi de ce type là on
même voté une hier sur les bourses
justement pour les qualités de manière
unanime pourquoi il n'a pas été évoqué
article 40 moi je me pose la question
donc en fait c'est un subterfuge de la
part du gouvernement pour empêcher qui
est un vote de l'Assemblée nationale ça
c'est très clair mais par contre ça ne
va pas empêcher des mobilisations à
nouveau j'espère massive le 6 juin
prochain pour justement montrer au
gouvernement que on se laissera pas
faire ça ne sera pas fini au moins
minimalement tant qu'il y aura pas eu
réellement une onction démocratique par
rapport à ce texte sur le fond est-ce
que vous reconnaissez que ce texte cette
proposition de loi du groupe priotte et
bien même si elle est adoptée par
l'Assemblée nationale elle n'a pas
d'avenir politique car la majorité de
droite ici au Sénat la rejetterait alors
après vous connaissez le circuit
c'est-à-dire que le Sénat rejette ça
peut revenir à nouveau à l'Assemblée
nationale et c'est l'Assemblée nationale
qui a de toute façon le dernier mot donc
après on va voir sur une provision ça
dépendra de la décision mais par contre
ce qui est intéressant c'est de voir ce
que va décider l'Assemblée nationale à
partir
qu'elle n'a pas voté parce que si elle
vote contre le signal qui est envoyé
quand même est assez terrible pour le
gouvernement
le signal est terrible et je pense que
le gouvernement qui s'entête doit
prendre en compte le rejet massif dans
la population et qu'elle n'est pas de
majorité politique de le pays pour
justement approuver ce texte autre sujet
qui a été évoqué par deux questions dans
cette séance de questions d'actualité
l'écriture inclusive il y a eu un examen
de droit à l'Université de Lyon écrit en
écriture inclusive vous êtes pour cette
méthode il y a de chanterelle alors moi
ce que je trouve assez hallucinant vous
avez vu il y a eu plusieurs questions de
la part de la droite sur ce sujet là
alors qu'on vient d'évoquer quand même
des sujets particulièrement graves notre
pays traverse une crise démocratique
particulièrement importante est-ce que
la droite trouve d'important d'évoquer
comme sujet c'est l'écriture inclusive
qu'est-ce qu'il est jeune dans le
l'écriture inclusive c'est peut-être le
mot inclusif je pense qu'il y a
certaines personnes qui aiment
l'entre-soi qui n'aiment pas l'inclusion
des autres de ceux qui sont différents
je pense que l'écriture inclusive il
faut qu'il y a un cadre est
effectivement pour que on puisse se
comprendre ou autre mais je pense que
c'est important aussi de savoir qu'on a
une langue qui n'est pas une langue
morte c'est une langue vivante qui
évolue qui fait son chemin aussi et ça
c'est important à prendre en compte
c'est un peu des guerres de vieilles
gardes qui sont pas du tout connectés
avec la réalité de la société merci
beaucoup
Ian chanterelle d'être venu au micro
Public Sénat merci merci beaucoup
Alexandre pour cette première réaction
pour ce débrief des questions au
gouvernement et on va rester salle des
conférences car également à votre micro
Roland Lescure le ministre de
l'Industrie et à nouveau pour revenir
sur la proposition de loi IOT pour
abroger la réforme des retraites
actuellement en débat en commission à
l'Assemblée et effectivement ce n'est
pas simple effectivement des débats très
tendus en commission des affaires
sociales à l'Assemblée nationale sur
cette proposition loi du groupe iode
bonjour Roland Lescure bonjour je vais
vous faire réagir à ce que vient de dire
le sénateur socialiste Yann chanterrel
est-ce qu'il y a d'une certaine manière
un coup de force du gouvernement pour
empêcher le vote sur cette proposition
de loi d'abrogation de la réforme des
retraites ben non en fait à votre il y
en a eu un il y a eu un vote dessus
pression en commission l'article 1 en
commission puis ensuite on verra ce qui
va se passer ça va cheminer mais la
majorité présidentielle ne souhaite pas
qu'il y ait de vote en hémicycle en
séance et vous savez quelle est la vie
du gouvernement même si évidemment c'est
une proposition de loi qui fera son
cheminement parlementaire le
gouvernement la première ministre l'a
dit et évidemment je suis d'accord avec
elle considère que cette proposition de
loyer non constitutionnelle parce
qu'elle crée une dépense importante non
chiffrée d'ailleurs de au moins 15
milliards d'euros qui viennent des
équilibrer les comptes et ça c'est
l'article 40 qui le dit il voulait un
vote sur cet article ils l'ont eu il a
été gagné par ceux qui souhaitaient
supprimer cet article de la proposition
de loi voilà on peut pas dire que la
démocratie n'a pas parlé quand il y a un
vote et puis quand il y a 49-3 et puis
quand il y a vérification est mise en
oeuvre de la Constitution il y a un
moment il faut qu'on puisse passer à
autre chose reconnaître que le débat a
eu lieu même s'il a eu lieu il faut le
reconnaître dans des conditions un peu
dégradées du fait de milliers
d'amendements qu'on a eu voilà
maintenant on peut avancer mais alors la
démocratie parlementaire ce n'est pas
que le vote en commission c'est aussi
sur l'hémicycle alors si vous vous
faites vous féliciter qu'il y a un vote
en commission pourquoi ne pas aller au
vote sur ce texte dans l'hémicycle le 8
juin prochain ben moi je regrette que
cette proposition de loi a été jugée
constitutionnel par le président de la
commission des finances moi j'ai été
président de commission pendant 5 ans
des
non-conformités avec la Constitution
alors c'était plutôt l'article 45 j'en
ai décidé des dizaines y compris
d'amendement qui venait évidemment de la
majorité de l'opposition et même du
gouvernement et moi je considère que
c'est l'eurol des présidents de
commission d'être les gardiens du temple
d'une certaine manière les gardiens de
la Constitution le président de la
commission des finances a souhaité aller
outre et aller au vote elle se vote il a
eu alors il y a cet argument
constitutionnel mais au fond ce qui
motive la position de la majorité
présidentielle et du gouvernement est-ce
que ce n'est pas la peur de perdre ce
vote sur l'abrogation de la réforme des
retraites non moi je pense que c'est
ouvrir la boîte de Pandore faut faire
attention quand même à jouer avec les
outils constitutionnels on peut se
retrouver et il faut le reconnaître y
compris dans une logique de majorité
relative et de majorité alternative au
Sénat avec des propositions de loi non
financées qui pourraient être votée et
qui mettrait du coup les comptes publics
en danger sans pour autant qu'on ait la
possibilité de les financer cet article
40 il est pas là pour faire plaisir
à Emmanuel Macron les habitborn au roi
en exclure il est là depuis plus de 50
ans parce que derrière c'est un syndic
40 il y a la volonté que quand on vote
on finance et si on finance pas on ne
vote pas dernière question Roland
Lescure sur le projet de loi industrie
verte que vous allez présenter ce soir
au sénateur avec le ministre de
l'Économie Bruno Le Maire est-ce que
c'est véritablement un projet de loi
Industri vert tout simplement un projet
de loi pour la réindustrialisation car
quand on entend les propos d'Emmanuel
Macron qui justement veut faire une
pause sur les normes environnementales
pour favoriser le retour des usines
donc d'abord on est content de commencer
au Sénat devant quatre commissions ça
montre bien que l'industrie ça concerne
tout le monde et en plus ça concerne les
territoires deux on veut à la fois
développer l'industrie verte et
réindustrialiser en verdissant
l'industrie traditionnelle donc on doit
à la fois verdir les assiérer les
hallumineries évidemment les
usines de voitures et développer
l'industrie de la décarbonation et on le
fait vous savez que les giga Factory
sont en train de pousser un peu partout
en France et notamment dans les
Hauts-de-France les usines d'hydrogène
les usines de pompe à chaleur les usines
de Pat de panneaux pardon
photovoltaïques pour qu'on est capable
de faire les deux la pose vous savez qui
s'était expliqué là-dessus et nous aussi
on a déjà engagé beaucoup de réformes au
niveau européen mets ton né en œuvre
montrant l'exemple l'Europe c'est le
continent le plus décarboné du monde la
France et le pays loin des pays les plus
décarbonés d'Europe soyons en fier et
continuons merci beaucoup Merci à VOUS
l'enlève pour votre réaction merci
beaucoup
à toutes ces Ré salle des conférences et
également à votre micro et bien on va
avoir également le sénateur LR de la
Manche à l'ex-président de la commission
des lois aujourd'hui caster du Sénat il
s'agit de Philippe Bas pour une nouvelle
réaction bien ce qui se passe à
l'Assemblée avec la proposition de loi
de l'iode pour abroger la réforme des
retraites notamment
la majorité présidentielle ont raison de
s'opposer de vouloir finalement qu'il
n'y ait pas de vote sur cette
proposition de loi du groupe lyaute pour
abroger la réforme des retraites et ce
qu'ils ont raison de le faire notamment
sur le plan démocratique est-ce que ça
ne va pas affaiblir la démocratie
parlementaire ce qui affaiblit la
démocratie c'est quand une loi est
promulguée c'est de la mettre en cause
le lendemain c'est pas sérieux et tout
le monde le voit et surtout dans le
néant des propositions alternatives
parce que si pour équilibrer nos régimes
de retraite c'est-à-dire pour assurer à
chaque Français
bonne pension de retraite on n'a pas
d'autre moyen que de faire après les
mouvements massif fiscal et social sur
les revenus des Français alors vraiment
c'est qu'on a aucune espèce
d'imagination non ceci n'est pas sérieux
ni du point de vue démocratique parce
que la réforme des retraites vient
d'être promulguées ni du point de vue
des idées politiques parce que c'est nul
de pouvoir s'imaginer que on va pouvoir
dans le pays dans les prélèvements
obligatoires sur les plus importants
encore ponctionner sur le revenu du
travail des Français
à tous égards on devrait maintenant
passer à des choses plus sérieuses et je
ne dis pas que cette réforme des
retraites a été faite avec tout le
dialogue social qu'il aurait fallu faire
en 2003 quand Jacques Chirac a réformé
les retraites il y a eu un accord avec
la CFDT et la CGC à l'époque et c'était
la manière de montrer que au fond on
sait écouter les autres peut-être que
cette réforme n'a pas été bien conduite
sur le plan du dialogue social
pas les fêtes et elle est responsables
mais sur le plan démocratique et ce
qu'il ne manque pas finalement un vote
de l'Assemblée nationale sur cette
réforme majeure mais alors
soumis et tous ceux qui ont fait de
l'obstruction qui a empêché que le débat
parlementaire porte sur le fond des
choses en multipliant les amendements
qui étaient tous les mêmes tous recopier
les uns sur les autres uniquement pour
pouvoir prendre la parole
continuellement et empêcher le débat
d'avancer qui a fait obstacle un travail
parlementaire de qualité mais il y a
aussi le 49-3 il empêchement du vote le
49,3 est provoqué très directement par
l'obstruction il faut quand même
remettre le clocher au milieu du visage
du village pardon les gens ont du bon
sens ils ont compris cela on peut être
contre une réforme on peut manifester
contre la réforme il faut le faire si on
est contre mais quand on est
représentant de la nation le minimum
qu'on puisse faire c'est tout de même de
délibérer sur le fond des choses de
faire valoir un point de vue et non pas
d'empêcher le débat d'avoir lieu chez
les bas dernières questions sur la loi
immigration puisqu'il y a des
tractations entre le gouvernement et les
républicains pour Sark s'accorder sur ce
texte Charles de Darmanin veut
travailler avec les républicains il veut
je cite que chacun fasse un pas est-ce
que les LR doivent par exemple retirer
leur propositions constitutionnelle de
pouvoir déroger à certains traités
européens pour et bien s'accorder avec
le gouvernement qui est contre cette
mesure permet de vous dire que la vraie
question c'est qu'est-ce qu'on fait pour
garantir la cohésion nationale quand
elle est mise en mal par une immigration
qui est sans contrôle aujourd'hui et
donc le gouvernement fait un projet de
loi nous le modifions en commission des
lois au Sénat il le retire il annonce
qu'il le remet puis il annonce qu'il le
retire maintenant il annonce que le
Conseil des ministres va délibérer sur
un nouveau projet vous connaissez
grand pays dont la politique navigue
d'un extrême à l'autre comme ça sans
arrêt il est grand temps que on
s'accorde en effet sur une politique
rigoureuse de l'immigration nous on sait
ce qu'il faut faire on l'a mis sur la
table et bien discutons-en et
discutons-en ce sera le mot de la fin
merci beaucoup Philippe d'être venu au
micro de Public Sénat merci merci
beaucoup Alexandre c'est le moment de
faire
le séance
de Gouvernement sur ce plateau j'ai le
plaisir d'accueillir Usain Bourget
bonjour vous êtes sénateur socialiste de
l'Hérault face à vous Corinne Imbert
bonjour bonjour vous êtes sénatrice de
la Charente-Maritime rattachée au groupe
LR et enfin Henri Cabanel est avec nous
sur ce plateau bonjour bonjour sénateur
RDSE de l'Hérault et on en a parlé à
l'instant et c'est la question qui a
ouvert la séance de questions au
Gouvernement celle qui a porté sur la
proposition de loi l'iode pour abroger
la réforme des retraites alors comment
ça s'est passé exactement en séance pour
cela on va rejoindre Quentin dans
l'hémicycle du Sénat et je le disais
c'est la question qui a ouvert cette
séance de questions gouvernement
de plus vivre tension dans cette séance
qui s'est ouverte à 15h on le répète
cette proposition de loi qui vise à
abroger la réforme des retraites a été
on peut le dire vider de sa substance
par un vote ce matin en commission des
affaires sociales de l'Assemblée
nationale et c'est donc le chef de fil
des écologistes du Sénat qui a attaqué
Elisabeth borne et son gouvernement
alors selon Guillaume Gontard il y
aurait une tentation autoritaire avec
l'examen de cette proposition de loi
écoutez le chef de fil des écologistes
au Sénat
ce matin
puisque la bataille de retraite qui est
jouée à l'Assemblée nationale en
torpillant une initiative
Parlement
vous créez un précédent délétère qui
menace de réduire à néant le droit
d'expression déjà famélique des
parlementaires madame la Première
ministre vous êtes une démocrate vous
l'avez clamé ici même en juillet 2022
comment pouvez-vous tolérer la dérive
autoritaire dans laquelle le président
vous enferme c'est la première ministre
qui a répondu à Guillaume Gontard
d'ailleurs elle a souri en prenant la
parole en l'entendant l'attaque de
Guillaume Gontard l'expression de dérive
autoritaire lui a sans doute sembler
excessive elle est revenue sur la
proposition de loi Eliott et plus
généralement sur les 175 heures dixit de
débat parlementaire sur la réforme des
retraites écoutez un extrait de sa
réponse
ce matin la commission des affaires
sociales de l'Assemblée nationale a voté
et à supprimer l'article de la
proposition de loi qui visait à abroger
la réforme des retraites c'est un vote
clair et démocratique mais immédiatement
après
laupasse a répondu par l'obstruction
avec le dépôt de 3000 sous amendements
pour empêcher un vote finale en
commission
la réalité c'est que lorsque le résultat
d'un vote déplaît à la nupasse elle n'a
qu'une réponse l'obstruction voilà une
réponse qui n'a pas convaincu
l'écologiste Guillaume Gontard qui a
parlé des événements comme une
Fossoyeuse de la démocratie française
merci beaucoup Quentin pour ce moment ce
temps fort effectivement qui a ouvert
cette séance est-ce que pour vous
Corinne Humbert il faut que la
proposition de loi liotte pour
labrogation de la réforme des retraites
puissent être débattus voté normalement
dans les muscles de l'assemblée
écoutez tout texte qui arrive dans une
assemblée que ça soit l'Assemblée
nationale ou c'est pas la commission
elle a été débattue en commission il y a
eu un vote la démocratie parlementaire
n'a pas été bafouée ce matin en
commission des affaires sociales de
l'Assemblée nationale me semble-t-il
après c'est le texte de la commission
qui est censé arriver dans l'hémicycle
c'est le revers de la médaille quand au
moment de la discussion de la réforme de
la retraite l'opposition gouvernement a
joué à fond la carte de l'obstruction
empêchant le débat empêchant un vote et
bien voilà on peut pas aujourd'hui
parler d'une démocratie qui est bafouée
par les autoritarisme etc je crois que
c'est un petit peu le revers de la
médaille je trouve que ça grandit pas
notre notre Parlement ça abîme au
contraire l'image du Parlement l'image
du fonctionnement du Parlement et je le
regrette voilà aujourd'hui là à l'heure
où on se parle ils sont partis dans une
obstruction avec un nouveau tout un tas
de sous amendements avec pour objet le
fait que
de la commission des affaires sociales
voilà mais voilà me semble-t-il pas une
bonne image ni un bon fonctionnement une
question alors c'est peut-être un peu de
la tambouille interne mais il y a deux
députés qui ont été changés à la
dernière minute pour c'est du côté des
lèvres d'ailleurs des députés qui ont le
savait été plutôt favorables à cette
proposition de loi d'abrogation qui a
été échangé avec des propos pour des
députés qui étaient plus favorables à la
position de la majorité présidentielle
est-ce que ça c'est pas un premier
problème tout de même écouter ça c'est
le règlement interne de l'Assemblée
nationale donc je peux pas m'exprimer
là-dessus je sais que j'ai vu cette
situation pour d'autres textes est
beaucoup moins polémique ou de députés
switcher pour que l'un puisse participer
aux travaux de commission sur un texte
qui n'avait pas du tout les mêmes
polémiques que la réforme des retraites
voilà donc écoutez ça c'est le règlement
et autorisé mais c'est pas très est-ce
que c'est normal
je peux pas me prononcer encore une fois
sur le normalité ça peut être cho voilà
ça choquant ça me choque normalement oui
s'il règlement de l'Assemblée nationale
le permet choquant à mes yeux oui mais
je partage sur le fond les propos de
Philippa sur la méthode et sur la façon
dont aujourd'hui on entend les critiques
de la part de de la nuit passée des
opposants
alors on le voit effectivement la gauche
a fini par boycotter par partir en
dénonçant des magouilles à la claquer la
porte de la commission des affaires
sociales à la raison je trouve que ce
qui s'est passé à l'Assemblée nationale
ce matin est très inquiétant on est dans
le droit fil de la philosophie de ce qui
s'est passé lors de l'examen du projet
de loi de réforme des retraites à savoir
des coups de force des tours de
passe-passe chez moi dans le sud on
appelle ça des joueurs de bonneto ça
avait son c'est charlatans qu'on trouve
sur la voie publique et qui vous font
perdre l'argent que vous misez en
l'occurrence ce qui s'est passé à
l'Assemblée nationale c'est fabriqué des
majorités sur mesure ensuite chant des
députés comme vous l'avez dit juste pour
remplacer les vérité qui était favorable
à la proposition de loi du groupe lyaute
par des députés qui étaient au contraire
défavorables ensuite il y a un droit qui
est on a le droit de le faire le
règlement
je trouve que c'est moral voilà première
chose deuxième chose il y a un droit qui
est sacré au Parlement lorsque je suis
arrivé on me l'a expliqué c'est le droit
d'amander nous avons le droit d'amander
au Sénat en amande un peu moins qu'à
l'Assemblée nationale où le faisons avec
beaucoup de responsabilités et beaucoup
de mesures et ce qui me frappe c'est
lorsqu'on fait tomber les amendements
par centaines ou par milliers ça devient
une forme de surenchère
les oppositions et finalement moi ce qui
m'interpelle dans cette histoire c'est
le regard que les citoyens les citoyens
posent sur nous parce que les hommes et
les femmes qui regardent de la
télévision qui écoutent la radio qui
lisent la presse finalement vont mettre
tout le monde dans le même sac et ça
nourrit l'anti parlementarisme
et effectivement on a l'impression que
c'est toujours le gouvernement qui gagne
quoi qu'on fasse ce qui conduit certains
m'interroger mais à quoi ça sert d'avoir
des parlementaires de l'opposition
qu'est-ce que ça vous inspire cette
situation aujourd'hui effectivement que
cette proposition de loi d'abrogation de
la réforme des retraites et bien elle
vire à la guérilla parlementaire à la
joute institutionnelle finalement plus
que le débat sur le fond
lamentable lamentable on donne une image
lamentable j'avais dit quand il y a eu
l'explication de vote sur le projet pour
vous tout le monde
je le répète quand j'ai fait ma mon
explication de votre au nom de mon
groupe je l'ai dit on a une
co-responsabilité c'est le Parlement
aujourd'hui
l'image désastreuse que nous ont montré
les députés lors de l'assemblée à
l'Assemblée nationale lors du débat cela
en réforme des retraites je pensais que
avec la responsabilité dont nous devons
avoir nous chacune et chacun des
parlementaires de ce pays on pourrait on
aurait pu attirer les leçons et se
sortir de mieux de la situation dans
laquelle on est et non
on a rien compris on s'enfonce encore
plus on dégrade encore plus notre image
de par le bancaire mais
moi je voilà aujourd'hui est-ce qu'il
faudrait que le débat puisse aller
jusqu'à son terme pour moi je rejoins
même si je ne partage pas les
convictions de Philippe Bas je rejoins
une Philippe Bas dans la responsabilité
qui nous est due en tant que
parlementaire on ne revient pas sur une
loi qui a été votée voilà c'est c'est
terminé
la façon dont ça c'est fait et moi
personnellement je l'ai dit sur le
véhicule législatif sur tout ce qui
s'est passé à l'Assemblée nationale une
fois qu'on a dit tout ça notre devoir
c'est de légiférer on a légiféré il y a
on a une constitution et on l'appliquait
qu'on critique la façon dont ça c'est
fait qu'on critique le 49.3 mais le 49-3
c'est vrai que ça empêche le débat mais
le droit
de s'initier mon collègue
us chirurgie de droit d'amendement quand
il y a autant d'amendements que ce qu'il
y a eu déposé c'est aussi une
obstruction au débat moi j'ai jamais vu
ça au Sénat depuis que je suis en 2014
quand on dépose une amendement en
général celui qui dépose la main de main
demande à ses collègues qui veulent le
signer la norme on a bien vu que la
règle n'était plus du tout la même
chacun apportait nominativement un
amendement avec la volonté de ne pas
faire de débats donc voilà moi je dis
que c'est lamentable que ce soit d'un
côté ou de l'autre et on n'est pas au
niveau on n'est pas au niveau en tant
que parlementaire des responsabilités
qui sont les nôtres pour apaiser parce
que on est dans une situation un petit
peu délicate et là on remue un petit peu
le couteau dans la plaie à mon envie
c'est de l'irresponsabilité oui
justement est-ce que ça alimenter la
contestation dans la rue est-ce que même
la gauche compte sur la façon dont ça se
passe ce débat pour que ça alimente
notamment la mobilisation du 6 juin je
ne pense pas objectivement je ne pense
pas mais il ne faut pas donner le
sentiment aux gens qu'ils ont manifesté
que ça n'a servi à rien qu'ils ont des
oppositions de gauche ou de droite qui
se sont exprimées à l'Assemblée
nationale et au Sénat que ça ne sert à
rien qu'il y a toujours des artifices
procédures il y a toujours des articles
dans les règlements intérieurs de
l'Assemblée et du Sénat il y a toujours
des articles dans la Constitution qui
permettent de passer en force finalement
toute cette affaire nous prouve sans
doute se terminer et là ce qui prouve
bien que nous ne sommes pas dans une
démocratie
pacifiée et apaisée que j'appelle de mes
vœux sur un projet de loi aussi
important lorsque vous n'avez pas une
majorité absolue en l'occurrence le
gouvernement n'a pas une majorité
absolue il aurait dû faire le choix de
construire une majorité en s'alliant
soit avec la droite parlementaire soit
avec la gauche parlementaire mais il a
fait le choix avec la droite il a fait
le choix finalement après avoir tenté de
saler avec la droite de passer en force
ce qui fait qu'effectivement il y a
personne qui est satisfait dans cette
histoire personne
est-ce que cela reflète du coup aussi un
problème d'ordre institutionnel
aujourd'hui pour vous Corinne Imbert et
pour revenir sur ce que vous disiez sur
la droite la droite n'a-t-elle pas sa
part de responsabilité dans tout cela
puisqu'effectivement le gouvernement
comptait sur les voies de la droite
elles n'ont pas manqué au Sénat et on
voit bien que ce sont les divisions à
l'Assemblée aussi qui ont mené la
situation
si je regrette à titre personnel et
division à droite à la semelle pour
autant chaque parlementaire est libre de
s'exprimer dans le sens qu'il le
souhaite je sais pas si ça remet en
cause nos institutions en tout cas au
Sénat débat parlementaires a quand même
eu lieu nous avons été jusqu'au bout du
texte ce qui me gêne plus c'est
qu'aujourd'hui on remette en cause une
loi qui était juste promulguée et
surtout alors que le pays a besoin de
sérénité on attise les braises on ravive
un peu les braises je suis pas sûr que
ce soit les bonnes méthodes voilà il y a
une réalité il y a une réalité
démographique vieillissement de la
population
cette réforme des retraites il me semble
qu'elle était nécessaire à titre
personnel et pour mon groupe ici au
Sénat nous étions favorables sinon
c'était soit des prélèvements plus
importants soit une baisse à terme des
pensions je pense que c'est en
responsabilité que nous avons soutenu le
texte au Sénat sur la méthode ce que
disait tout à l'heure Philippe bam les
consultations en amont du texte le
véhicule législatif on en a débattu à un
moment donné il y a beaucoup de choses à
redire mais quand même la loi est votée
la loi est promulguée le respect du
Parlement c'est aussi ça voilà on va
passer à notre temps fort de cette
séance de questions au gouvernement
c'est en force ce sont il y a les deux
questions qui ont été posées sur la
fraude sociale alors que le gouvernement
est bien dévoilé son plan en début de
semaine et d'ailleurs Gabriel Attal le
ministre des contes publics est revenu
sur le sujet dans l'amitié on l'écoute
vous m'interrogez sur la carte Vitale
biométrique c'est une proposition
effectivement qui a été émise à
plusieurs reprises ici même nous avons
confié à l'Inspection générale des
affaires sociales et à l'Inspection
générale des finances une mission sur le
sujet le rapport a été remis à quelques
jours il est à votre disposition que dit
ce rapport un ça coûterait très cher 250
millions d'euros par an 2 il y a de
vrais freins juridiques et la CNIL
s'oppose à cette mesure 3 il y a des
freins pratiques les syndicats de
médecins dans le rapport disent
eux-mêmes qu'ici oppose et par ailleurs
il y a des fins pratiques aujourd'hui si
vous êtes cloué au lit que vous envoyez
votre proche cherchez vos médicaments à
la pharmacie si vous donnez si vous
devez donner vos empreintes pour avoir
vos médicaments convenait que c'est
assez compliqué voilà donc le
gouvernement qui ne veut pas de la carte
Vitale biométrique mais tu lui préfères
la fusion de la carte vitale et de la
carte d'identité tout ça dans un tout un
plan qui a été dévoilé pour lutter
contre la fraude sociale Usain Bourget
est-ce que c'est important de prendre
ces mesures c'est légitime c'est
démagogique comme on l'a entendu chez
certains
il faut juste dire certaines choses pour
que les téléspectateurs nous comprennent
la fraude de cotisations sociales chaque
année en France c'est 8 milliards la
fraude à la CAF la Caisse d'Allocations
Familiales chaque année en France c'est
2 milliards lorsque vous additionnez les
deux types de fraudes dont il s'agit ça
représente 10 milliards la fraude
fiscale c'est 100 milliards donc moi je
souhaiterais juste que le gouvernement
mette autant d'emprunt dans la lutte
contre la fraude fiscale que contre la
fraude sociale
et j'attends d'avoir les résultats parce
qu'il ne faut pas avoir une conception
uniquement hémiplégique
de la lutte contre les fraudes il faut
lutter contre toutes les formes de
fraude parce que la fraude c'est
l'argent public c'est l'argent du
contribuable c'est l'argent de chacun et
chacune qui contribuent à l'effort de la
nation donc oui il faut lutter contre la
fraude et la cotisation sociale oui il
faut lutter contre la fraude que subit
la cave chaque année mais il faut aussi
aller chercher l'argent dans les paradis
fiscaux il faut davantage peser pour une
coopération européenne internationale
entre les différents états pour
justement traquer la faute cruciale
parce qu'on a besoin d'argent public on
a besoin d'argent public pour financer
et pour permettre la pérennité de notre
modèle social français l'État-providence
à la française le système de retraite
par répartition nous avons besoin
d'argent pour le financer tout cela et
il faut aller chercher l'argent là où il
est Henri Cabanel on entend Étienne
projet qui parle de gouvernement
potentiellement émislégique il y a
attaque qui a dénoncé une asymétrie
entre la lutte contre la fraude fiscale
et la lutte contre la fraude sociale
est-ce que c'est le cas pour vous
d'abord la mission d'un gouvernement
c'est de lutter contre la fraude ça
c'est la première démission et donc je
me réjouis effectivement que des
décisions aient été prises dans dans ce
sens mais comme vient de le rappeler mon
collègue
Usain Bourget il faut que ça soit
proportionné donc effectivement moi je
suis heureux de voir les moyennes qui
ont été mis donc plus de 1000 TP prévu
pour lutter contre la fraude fiscale
sociale c'est très bien il faudrait que
proportionnellement pour lutter contre
la fraude fiscale il y est autant de TP
un Baucher parce que effectivement c'est
10 fois plus 10 fois plus et je crois
que le gouvernement doit faire le
nécessaire auprès donc des autres pays
européens pour être le faire de lance et
en tout cas essayer de supprimer les
paradis fiscaux je rappelle
c'est 10 fois plus la foi du faux il
faut faire le nécessaire mais là on est
à 10 fois plus on parle de 100 milliards
5 milliards et 100 milliards je suis
désolé mais aujourd'hui en Europe on a
Malte Chypre Irlande de Luxembourg
Pays-Bas qui sont les parents
se concentrer sur la route quelle
qu'elle soit mais il faut mettre les
moyens proportionnées en fonction de la
fraude on est à 8 à 10 milliards sur la
Ford fiscale sociale on est à 100
milliards sur la foire de fiscale et
paradis fiscaux vos collègues estiment
qu'il n'y a pas assez d'efforts mis sur
la fraude fiscale alors que bon le débat
la porte sur la fraude sociale votre
avis Corinne Imbert ni la fraude fiscale
ni la fraude sociale ne sont admissibles
de toute façon ça c'est clair je pense
qu'on nous sommes d'accord tous les
trois là effectivement le sujet c'est de
la fraude sociale il y a une réalité au
palmier même si c'est dix fois moins que
la fraude la fraude fiscale est elle
existe sur les moyens mis en place en
tout cas affichée par le gouvernement
très bien allons-y sur les moyens
techniques avec la fusion de la carte
d'identité et de la carte Vitale je suis
un peu inquiète j'espère que compte tenu
des difficultés à fabriquer les cartes
d'identité aujourd'hui d'abord j'imagine
que le temps sera long avant que cette
mesure soit mise en oeuvre parce que
d'après ce que j'ai compris ça sera vous
cette nouvelle carte quand votre carte
d'identité ne sera plus valable donc
j'espère qu'il y aura pas de problème
technique j'espère qu'il y aura pas du
coup puisque la même carte regroupera à
la fois la carte Vitale la carte
d'identité il y aura pas de rupture
d'accès aux soins même si aujourd'hui
même si vous n'avez pas votre carte
Vitale et vous allez chercher des
médicaments le pharmacien appartement
pourra vous délivrer mes médicaments
mais donc voilà donc ça fait un petit
peu peur de l'usine à gaz que ça
pourrait représenter exactement j'ai
peur d'une usine à gaz maintenant il
faut essayer il y a suffisamment de
longtemps gratter qu'on a abandonné la
carte Vitale biométrique qui était la
proposition du Sénat et en cours
d'expérimentation au niveau des
matérialisé c'est une proposition que
nous avons présenté soutenu voter je le
regrette alors j'entends les les
observations de la CNIL et l'observation
de la de la ministre aujourd'hui les
mêmes patients qui sont chez eux alités
qui peuvent pas venir à l'officine
chercher leur médicament quelqu'un vient
pour autant il me semble que les
médicaments sont délivrés donc je pense
pas que ça aurait fait obstacle ça reste
à la marge donc de toute façon bon on
verra bien on verra si c'est une husenie
à gaz ou pas l'essentiel c'est qu'on
avance sur ce sujet là comme sur le
sujet de la fraude fiscale mais qui est
beaucoup plus compliqué parce que la
fiscalité et les paradis fiscaux des
autres pays après c'est de la gérance
etc voilà il y a le chantier n'est pas
le même il y a un sujet quand même c'est
celui du non recours aux prestations
sociales 40% des personnes qui ont droit
au RSA ne le touchent pas en moyenne le
taux de nos recours et de
30%, c'est aussi le sujet le corollaire
de de ce sujet de lutte contre l'Afrique
effectivement on a beaucoup de personnes
qui sont aujourd'hui dans la précarité
qui pourrait bénéficier de ces aides et
qui n'ayant pas recours tout simplement
parce qu'ils ne sont pas informés parce
que les dossiers à remplir ce fond de
manière numérique et qu'ils sont
éloignés de tout ce monde-là et donc ce
qui fait qu'aujourd'hui on a beaucoup de
Français de français qu'on pourrait
sortir de la précarité qu'on pourrait
sortir de la pauvreté tout simplement en
leur octroyant les droits auxquels ils
ont
justement droit aujourd'hui parce qu'ils
ont cotisé et comme tout le monde ils
ont droit à ses aides et assez minima
sociaux et ils n'ont pas recours
malheureusement est-ce que vous jugez la
prise de parole du gouvernement
équilibrer sur cette question de la
fraude sociale on en a entendu à gauche
qui estime que on va bien sur le terrain
de de la fraude des pauvres de LA qui
qui estime que c'est un débat qui est
les étrangers avec laquelle ce procès là
au gouvernement je ne ferai pas ce
procès là au gouvernement mais pour que
le gouvernement soit au-dessus de tout
soupçon il faut qu'il mette autant
d'emprunt autant de Z dans la lutte
contre la froide fiscale contre la
fraude sociale j'irai l'équilibre je
reviens vraiment oui effectivement parce
qu'une politique équilibrée elle doit
reposer sur ces deux pieds traquer la
fraude sociale en France les 10
milliards dont il est question c'est
bien mais se donner les moyens de
convaincre les partenaires européens de
convaincre les partenaires sur la scène
internationale pour lutter contre la
fraude fiscale là c'est beaucoup plus
difficile et je pense qu'il peut y avoir
un consensus politique et le
gouvernement pourrait en sortir
justement gagnant en montrant et en
donnant la preuve qu'il a à cœur de
lutter contre les deux formes de fraude
allez un dernier thème qui a marqué
cette séance de questions au
gouvernement et pour cela on va
rejoindre
pas calmer dans l'hémicycle du Sénat
Quentin car il y a une autre question
qui a attiré notre attention tout à
l'heure une question qui concerne l'IHU
de Marseille absolument en time il a été
question de Didier Raoult ce professeur
de médecine donc il ne faut pas
prononcer le nom car effectivement et
bien on a évoqué ce professeur mais sans
dire explicitement son nom ses signes
aussi et bien du niveau et voilà et de
l'intérêt de de cette question une
question venue du socialiste Bernard
gomier qui depuis trois ans s'interroge
sur les pratiques qui se sont tenues à
l'Institut hospital universitaire et et
bien cette institut à Marseille qui est
en ce moment et bien sous les coups
d'une perquisition qui est en cours avec
des gendarmes et une juge d'instruction
c'est ce qui a révélé le JDD et quelques
heures alors ces dernières semaines il y
a des soupçons qui pèsent sur la
possibilité que l'IHU aurait tenu un
essai clinique géant sauvage sur 30 000
patients 16
savantes de médecine s'en était ému dans
le journal Le Monde ce week-end écouter
la réponse du ministre de la Santé tout
à l'heure de la séance comme vous je
déplore ce nouvel épisode
inadmissible de cette affaire sachant
que la justice est en train de suivre
son cours comme vous avez pu le
constater avec moi dès ce matin devant
cette publication qui pourrait cette
proposition de publication qui pour moi
s'apparente a de la provocation nous
serons amenés et l'étude est en cours
avec les services juridique apprendre
avec ma collègue Sylvie Retailleau pour
l'enseignement supérieur à la recherche
et moi-même toutes les mesures
nécessaires envers l'ensemble des
signatures de cet article cette réponse
n'a pas convaincu le sénateur socialiste
Bernard jomet qui avait posé la question
et qui avait alerté y compris lors d'une
de ces séances de questions gouvernement
par exemple en janvier 2022 on s'en
rappelle Tam Bernard jaumier avait dit
que Didier Raoult discréditait la
politique en faveur du vaccin écoutez
maintenant en 2023 l'analyse de Bernard
jaumier
monsieur le ministre je pense que
vous-même avez conscience de la
faiblesse de votre réponse
il y a deux ans
alertes étaient déjà nombreuses les
rapports de la NSM les rapports de
ligase et bien avant en 2015 l'Inserm
quitté le conseil d'administration de
l'iachu Méditerranée
café l'Université d'Aix-Marseille pour
mettre fin à ses dérives rien
qu'avez-vous fait messieurs les
ministres monsieur Véran vous étiez
ministre de la Santé vous n'avez pas
répondu à la question écrite que j'ai
déposée concernant les dérives de l'IU
madame Frédéric Vidal ministre de la
Recherche n'a pas répondu non plus à mes
questions et bien si l'ensemble des
institutions de notre pays et les
ministres se sont tu et on fait preuve
des faiblesses c'est peut-être parce que
le chef de l'État et allait couvrir de
sa chaleureuse immunité le patron de
l'iachu et c'est un dysfonctionnement
grave de nos institutions et c'est vrai
qu'Emmanuel Macron et le professeur
Raoult c'était rencontré assez tôt
d'ailleurs c'était le 9 avril 2020 assez
tôt lors de et bien cette crise
sanitaire Tam merci merci
aussi de ce qui c'est un peu passé
pendant le covid c'est scientifiques
devenu des superstars d'une parole
scientifique qui a pu aussi verser dans
le populisme médical qu'est-ce que ça
vous inspire corinabé est-ce qu'il y a
aussi eu du coup face à ce phénomène une
inaction des autorités c'est ce que
c'est ce qui estime Bernard jaumier
c'est ce qu'il a répondu dans sa
réplique tout à l'heure effectivement
c'est ce qu'il estime et enfin moi ce
qui me choque c'est quand on parle
d'essai cliniques sauvage et c'est une
réalité 30 000 patients 30 000 patients
vous savez que depuis 1988 il y a une
loi qui encadre les essais cliniques sur
les médicaments avec une protection
comme objectif de protéger les personnes
qui participent à ces essais cliniques
il est bien normal que des personnes qui
participent à des essais cliniques
demain nous permettront d'avoir des
médicaments qui nous permettent
d'avancer de soigner des pathologies
soit protégées donc ces essais cliniques
sauvages se sont assis sur la loi non
seulement pourquoi parce que il faut la
vie du comité de protection des
personnes et il faut notorisation de
l'agence de sécurité du médicament ni
l'un ni l'autre n'ont été donné
et accordé aux professionnels
énorme quand même c'est énorme c'est
aussi peut-être à la fois je me demande
si c'est médecin on pas
affoler ou pas proposé quelque chose
qu'elle allait être la solution face à
une panique générale face à cette
pandémie on profitait donc de la
faiblesse aussi des patients et de
l'inquiétude de tout le monde enfin faut
se remettre dans le contact actuel mais
ceci n'excuse pas
qu'on puisse ne pas respecter la
protection des personnes et se permettre
des essais cliniques comme cela ce n'est
pas acceptable ce n'est pas acceptable
et c'est un vrai scandale alors
maintenant effectivement je partage je
partagerai pas la dernière phrase sur la
relation entre Emmanuel Macron a été
rendu
mais en tout cas sur la lenteur des
décisions nous sommes trois ans après le
début de la pandémie il y a eu un
rapport qui a été remis il y a plus de
six mois au gouvernement au procureur je
trouve que les choses avancent lentement
sur ce sujet là mais en tout cas qu'on
parle de ces cliniques sauvages c'est
proprement scandaleux que c'est plus se
tenir ainsi en faisant un petit peu
croire aux gens qu'on avait le remède
miracle Henri Cabanel effectivement
30000 patients victimes de décès
cliniques sauvages ça vous choque aussi
bien sûr je pense qu'il y a eu un manque
comment des règles éthiques et
déontologie et je réfléchir voilà et je
pense que
notre collègue Chaumier à réseau
le gouvernement n'a pas
assumé ses responsabilités et n'a pas dû
voir la gravité dans laquelle se sont
menées ces essais et quand il signifie
qu'il avait fait des des questions
écrites là aussi
et c'est là que je veux insister c'est
inadmissible inadmissible quand un
parlementaire interroge un ministre le
ministre laps de temps pour les potes
mais il doit son devoir c'est d'y
répondre et le fait de peut pas répondre
ça veut dire de mettre de faire la
politique de l'autruche de dire mais
attendons que ça passe on verra donc là
oui je pense qu'il y a une volonté de
mettre ça sous le tapis
ça veut dire
et quand ton gouvertement un
gouvernement doute c'est pas bon signe
quoi on doit assumer ses responsabilités
quand on est aux affaires et il faut
avoir le courage aussi d'aller jusqu'au
bout de la démarche là il n'y ait pas
d'aller et quel que soit le ministre de
la Santé qui a été au responsabilité je
crois que c'est le manquement grave le
gouvernement a-t-il manqué de courage
Usain Bourget ça doit aussi nous faire
bien sûr
de dire Raoul ça a été aussi un peu le
gourou charismatique dans les médias
aussi dont on a peut-être aussi usé
abusé c'est un moment où il faut tout le
monde va regarder comment il s'est
comporté alors moi je suis parti du
raisonnement qui a été posé par ma
collègue Corinne Imbert et je parle sous
son contrôle parce qu'elle est
pharmacien donc c'est une question de
santé publique et si on ne sentait
publique et les essais cliniques sont
encadrés en France comme elle l'a dit 30
000 personnes qu'on intègre dans un
essai clinique sauvage c'est 30 000
personnes dont on met potentiellement la
vie en danger
première chose c'est la raison pour
laquelle il y a un cadre pour mener ces
essais cliniques la seconde chose vous
m'interrogez sur une dimension beaucoup
plus politique est-ce que le
gouvernement a manqué de courage moi je
vois dans cette affaire davantage de la
gêne de la gêne de la part des ministres
et en l'occurrence je rejoins des propos
de mon collègue Bernard jaumier qui au
Sénat a fait autorité à travers ses
travaux de lorsqu'il y a le l'apparition
de la pandémie du covid il a suivi cette
pandémie l'évolution justement des
protocoles sanitaires pendant toute
cette période et à essayer de nous
éclairer de mieux possible grâce aux
autres collègues qui sont issus du bloc
médical on a beaucoup de médecins on a
beaucoup de pharmaciens ici au Sénat et
nous avons essayé de nous forger une
conviction qui était assise qui était
adossée à ce que les sociétés savantes
ce que les organismes d'état pouvaient
nous dire à ce moment-là mais
naturellement lorsque vous avez le
président de la République qui va à
Marseille pour se mettre en scène avec
le gourou qui fait la une de la presse
et des médias à l'époque